KIM EVERYONE WELCOME TO THIS
MORNING'S ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE HEARING AS
SOON AS ONE OF MY- AMAZING
FANTASTIC AND GOOD LOOKING
INTELLIGENT SMART FUNNY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES SHOW UP.
WE WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
VICE CHAIR FLORA I'M ALWAYS
HAPPY TO SEE YOU BUT NEVER
HAPPIER THAN RIGHT NOW. IF
WELCOME AGAIN TO THIS MORNING'S
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE HEARING WE
HAVE FIFTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
HEARING AGENDA INCLUDING THE
FOLLOWING THREE BILLS THAT ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT A. B.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY EIGHT AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE COTTOM NOW
OUTNUMBERED THIS IS SCARY AND AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY FOUR IT DOES
THE DALLAS I'M NOT COOL WITH IT.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WHILE IT'S
COMMITTEES USUAL PRACTICE IS T
ALLOW FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY BY
TELEPHONE DUE TO TECHNICAL
LIMITATIONS WE WILL ONLY BE ABLE
TO ACCEPT COMMENTS DELIVERED IN
PERSON. BY WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
HERE TODAY. FOR THOSE UNABLE TO
BE HERE IN PERSON I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL. ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WE WILL BE
LIMITING TESTIMONY TO TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES PER BILL. TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THEN STATE
THEIR NAME AND ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. WITH THAT
SAID LET'S BEGIN TODAY'S
HEARING- AND I SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NGUYEN. IS HERE FOR A BI
SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MORNING
THANK YOU- IF THERE'S ONE
UNDENIABLE FACT THAT I CAN SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE TODAY IT
WOULD BE THAT OUR STATE IS IN
CRISIS MANY OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE ARE FACING TODAY ON OUR
STREETS AND IN OUR COMMUNITIES
LIKE THE HOMELESS AND NOW GONE
ABUSE DRUG ABUSE ALSO STEM FROM
AN TREATED MENTAL ILLNESS
FURTHER ADDING TO THIS PROBLEM
IS THE ONGOING STORAGE OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
CALIFORNIA AS IS THE PANDEMIC.
THE SUPPLY PROFESSIONAL HAS NOT
GROWN AMID RISING DEMAND FOR
SERVICES. DURING THE PANDEMIC
LOCKDOWNS THE IMPORTANCE OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS
BECOME. BECAME A TOPIC OF
URGENCY. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FOUNDATION. 64% IT OTHERS
RESPONDENT POLL SHARE THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH MENTAL. OR
EMOTIONAL HEALTH I GOT WORSE. A
LOT WORSE SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC. ADDITIONALLY 91% OF
PROVIDERS SURVEY REPORTED AN
INCREASE IN PATIENTS EXPERIENCE
A RANGE OF MENTAL HEALTH
ILLNESSES INCLUDE DEPRESSION.
SELF RELATED DISORDERS AND
SUICIDAL THOUGHTS. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE IT WAS
REPORTED THAT OVER TWO FOUR
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS DIE FROM
SUICIDE. AS ATTITUDES
SURROUNDING MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELLNESS HAVE EVOLVED OVER THE
PAST DECADE MORE PEOPLE ARE
FINDINGA LOT EASIER TO ASK FOR
THE HEALTH THEY ARE SEEKING. AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE ADDRESSES
THE GROWING DEMAND FOR MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS BY CREATING
A GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN THE
EXISTING MENTAL HEALTH.
PRACTITIONER FUND TO HELP REPAY
SCHOOL LOANS FOR INDIVIDUALS
PURSUING A CAREER AS A MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL AND HAVE
COMMITTED TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS.
SUPPORTING SUICIDE PREVENTION
HOTLINES ORGANIZATION A FEW
CALLS RECEIVED BY SUICIDAL.
PREVENTION HOTLINES. THIS BILL
IS A MEASURE THAT WOULD HELP PUT
MORE BOOTS ON THE GROUND. AS WE
CONTINUE TO FACE A GROWING
CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND OTHER MENTAL HEALTH
RELATED ISSUES AND THE STATE.
WITH THAT I ASKED RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I DON'T BELIEVE.
WITNESSES. WAS WITNESSES. THANKS
SO IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION- BUT IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE CHAMBERS WHO
WANTS IN IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WANTS TO- ADD ON LET'S FIRST
START WITH IN SUPPORT. ANYBODY
ONE THAT WANTS TO ADD ON. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SEEN ON
ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO THAT ON IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. ELIANA
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION FOR
THE REASONS STATED IN THE
ANALYSIS WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION SAYING NINE ONE
BRING BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ADULT
WEBER. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR- PRESENTING TODAY AND
FOCUSING ON MENTAL HEALTH
BECAUSE THAT IS DEFINITELY AN
ISSUE THAT WE AS A SOCIETY NEED
TO FOCUS ON A LOT MORE- I DO
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT. THIS
LOAN- WHEN YOU SAY REPAY
EDUCATIONAL LOANS WHAT EXACTLY
DO YOU MEAN BY THAT DO YOU MEAN
ALL LOANS UNDERGRAD GRADUATE
SCHOOL- WHAT THEY HAVE NOW IS A
SPECIFIC GRANT PROGRAM. OUR
PEOPLE CAN APPLY THING FOR UP TO
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS LIKE
THREE TIMES SO WHAT IS. THE
THOUGHT PROCESS BEHIND THIS
EDUCATION MY UNDERSTANDING WITH
THIS BILL IT'S SPECIFIC FOR GRAD
. PROGRAM AND IT'S A GRANT OKAY
AND IS THERE A CERTAIN AMOUNT
THAT YOU WERE THINKING WOULD BE-
PROBLEMA. WE DON'T OKAY AND
BECAUSE THE REASON IS BECAUSE IT
VARIES DEPENDING ON THE SCHOOL
AS WELL SO THAT'S WHY. I MEAN
THE LOAN ITSELF COULD BE SMALL
LARGE DEPENDING ON SO YOU'RE
KIND OF LEFT IT OPEN MEET
REPAYMENT OF THE LOAN- THAT'S
WHERE WHO. HOPING. FOR OKAY I'M
AND THEN AS FAR AS FINDING- ARE
WE- DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA OF HOW
MUCH FUNDING YOU'D BE ASKING FOR
. THIS WOULD NEED. IT. WITH THE
LOCAL INCOME. I'M SORRY THE
MINUTE. CERTAIN THE FUNDING
ITSELF IS IN THE CURRENT MENTAL
HEALTH PETITIONER EDUCATION FUND
THE EXISTING AND THEN OF COURSE
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE
APPROPRIATION OF THIS YOU KNOW
OF OUR FLESHLY BODY AGREES TO GO
FORWARD. OKAY SO EASILY ALLOW
THIS AS PART OF THAT FUNDING TO
BE USED SO WOULD YOU BE TAKING
AWAY FROM ANY OF THE CURRENT
FUNDING THAT IS ALREADY
DESIGNATED FOR THAT OTHER
PROGRAMS. I DON'T BELIEVE SO
OKAY AND HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THE OPPOSITION WITH THE FACT
THAT THIS KIND OF EXTEND TO- YOU
KNOW THOSE FOR PROFIT FACILITIES
THEIR ART THERE IS NO AYE
SPECIFICATION THAT THEY NEED TO
BE LIKE AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES JUST THAT THEY WORK
AT A SUICIDE OR A PLACE WHERE A
SUICIDE HOTLINE MAY REFER THEM
TO WHICH I'M ASSUMING IS. A
SUICIDE HOTLINE WOULD. I PREFER
TO PROBABLY ANY MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITY SO YES THE I'M SORRY ON
INTERRUPT ON THE THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY JUST FOR NONPROFIT
IT'S NOT FOR PROFIT. OKAY SO
IT'S SPECIFIC FOR NONPROFIT BUT
ANY PARTICULAR AREA SO IT COULD
BE. YOU KNOW IN AN UNDERSERVED
AREA OR FOR AN OVER SERVED AREA
. I'M. I GET YEAH I GUESS I MEAN
WE COULD THERE ARE DOWN TO
UNDERSERVED AREA BUT I THINK
MENTAL HEALTH I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANYWHERE THAT'S OVER
SERVE I DON'T THINK YOU SEE ANY
LOCATIONS IN CALIFORNIA HAS MORE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS THAT
THEY NEED- I THINK IT'S ACROSS
THE STATE. THE NEED IS AND IS
THERE FOR EVERY FURTHER ACROSS
THE STATE STATE SO I DON'T
THINK. OF FROM OUR RESEARCH IS
THAT IT'S UNDERSERVED ALL ACROSS
THE STATE AND NOT. WE HAVEN'T
SEEN IN THE AREA IF YOU KNOW OF
THEM LET US KNOW WE CAN MAYBE.
OF AMEND THE BILL TO SPECIFIC
SAID NOT IN THAT AREA- WELL I
THINK I THINK LIKE WITH ANY KIND
OF MEDICAL SERVICE THERE ARE
CERTAIN AREAS THAT HAVE- MORE
PROVIDERS WHETHER IT'S MEDICAL
DENTAL OR- YOU KNOW MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS IN WHICH YOU
FIND IN SOME OTHER AREAS AND SO
I THINK WITH. THIS FUND THIS
ORIGINAL FUN IT'S REALLY. TRYING
TO FOCUS ON PROVIDING MORE- THAN
TO HEALTH PROVIDERS IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS. I THOUGHT
ABOUT MAYBE ADDING THAT INTO THE
BILL SINCE THAT IS A- KEY
COMPONENT OF THE OPPOSITION I'M
- WELL FIRST I DO AGREE WITH YOU
WHEN IT COMES TO MEDICAL
SERVICES WE IN THIS BODY HAS
ALWAYS TARGET AREAS THAT
UNDERSERVED. EIGHT MEDICAL UN
DOES IS SEEKING MEDICAL HELP
ESPECIALLY RURAL AREAS AS A MUCH
MUCH HARDER DIFFICULT TIME THAN
THOSE OF US SAY AN ORANGE COUNTY
OR LOS ANGELES OR SAN DIEGO
EIGHT. SO I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THAT. OUR PURPOSE OF
THE BILL HAS BEEN IS TO LOOK AT
MENTAL HEALTH IN GENERAL BECAUSE
THAT'S A CRISIS ACROSS THE
STATE- BUT I'M HEARING YOUR
CONCERN I HAVE NO PROBLEM. AT A
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE TO NARROW IT
DOWN TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
DOESN'T GO INTO AREAS THAT HAS
WAY TOO MANY MENTAL HEALTH-
PROFESSIONAL WHICH AGAIN I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY AREAS IN
CALIFORNIA- I UNDERSTAND THE
MEDICAL SIDE. BUT IN TERMS OF
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS ACROSS SO-
WE ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO LOOK
AT IT AND NARROW IT DOWN. I
WOULD- STRONGLY I DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH OFFICES WORKED WITH- THE
OPPOSITION. BUT I WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT YOU YOU WON'T
WORK WITH THEM TO TRY TO- CLEAR
UP SOME OF THESE DISCREPANCIES
BETWEEN WHAT YOU ARE PROPOSING
VERSUS WHAT THE CURRENT-
REPAYMENT LOAN REPAYMENT GRANT
PROGRAM HAS- SO TODAY I WILL.
SUPPORT IT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE PROVIDE. MORE
WERE SERVICES IN THE AREA MENTAL
HEALTH- BUT I DO HOPE THAT THIS
IS CLEARED UP AS IT. CONTINUES
TO MOVE ALONG THE PATH. YEAH NO-
MY IN THE STANDS OUR OFFICE HAS
BEEN IN COMMUNICATION WITH THEM-
AND HAVE. TRIED TO WORK ON SOME
OF THE ISSUES THIS LETTERS WAS
GIVEN TO US LIKE A WEEK AGO. SO
KIND OF HARD TO TRY TO GET
EVERYTHING UNDER THERE BUT
THEY'VE BEEN ADDRESSING BUT
PRICE THAT WE'VE BEEN INCOME
CONVERSATION- BUT WE DIDN'T KNOW
THE SPECIFICS INTO ABOUT A WEEK
AGO WE WILL CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THEM. BUT
AGAIN THIS IS SPECIFIC. NOT
AFFORD. THE NOT FOR PROFIT.
ORGANIZATIONS THANK YOU. YOU
TALKED WEBER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE-
SO MEMBER I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
N HIGHLIGHTING THE IMPORTANCE
OFOUR MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
IN WORKFORCE SHORTAGES. I AGREE
THAT WE SHOULD CREATE MORE
INCENTIVES FOR A MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS IN CREATING INCENTIVES
FOR PROVIDERS SERVING AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHO
LACK ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES- AND SO YEAH I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION THAT
JUST HAPPENED WANT TO-
ENCOURAGE- THE AUTHOR- TO
SUPPORT THE PRIORITIZATION OF
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS AND
ENCOURAGE YOU TO AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'RE MORE THAN ONE DAY TO
KEEP WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
ON THAT ISSUE- I HOPE THIS
LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZES THIS
NEED. AND ENSURES ADEQUATE
RESOURCES A RESERVE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF RECRUITING AND
RETAINING OUR NEXT GENERATION OF
MENTAL HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WE
MUST CONTINUE TO BUILD THE
WORKFORCE THAT WILL SERVE ALL
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY THE
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA- AND WHEN THE TIME
COMES ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM I'LL
BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT BILL YOU
MUCH. MESSAGE THANK YOU MEMBERS
YOU. STOP WE HAVE A ITEM NUMBER
ON THE AGENDA- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI WITH AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY. GOOD MORNING GOMEZ CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT-
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY. I'M SURE I'M
NOT THE ONLY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHO HAS SEEN A DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN THE- THEFT OF CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS- IT'S HAPPENING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE MISTER
CHAIRMAN I SUSPECT THAT YOU HAVE
A SLEW OF TELECONVERTER BILLS
THAT TO. THAT YOU WILL BE
HEARING TO AND THIS COMMITTEE SO
I GUESS I GUESS I AM NOT SURE
FROM THE FIRST UP AT- YOU ARE
YOU ARE SIR THANK YOU AYE AYE. I
FEEL THE PRESSURE- SO THIS BILL
THE CORE OF THIS BILL IS REALLY
TO PROHIBIT A CORE RECYCLER HE
TO RECYCLERS CHOP SHOPS JUNK
DEALERS FROM PURCHASING A
CATALYTIC CONVERTER FROM ANYONE
OTHER THAN A LICENSED COMMERCIAL
ENTERPRISE OR THE ACTUAL OWNER
OF THE VEHICLE FROM WHICH THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTER HAS BEEN
REMOVED- WE WE'VE SEEN THE DATA
THAT THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS-
SITES TODAY. THE DATA YOU KNOW
FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THERE WAS ONLY A LITTLE OVER A
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED CATALYTIC
CONVERTER THEFTS REPORTED IN THE
ENTIRE YEAR IN THIS CALIFORNIA.
WHEREAS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
JUST IN THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS
OVER EIGHT THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
HOWEVER REPORTED THAT THEIR
CATALYTIC CONVERTER HAD BEEN
STOLEN. THESE THEFTS ARE BEING
DRIVEN BY THE DESIRE TO SEEK
SOME OF THE PRECIOUS AND
EXPENSIVE METALS IN THESE
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS- WHERE THEY
MELT THESE DOWN AND- AND
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS A- A
MARKET FOR THESE METALS- BUT- WE
ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS.
AKHIR THIS YOU KNOW. SEARCH THE
SPIKE IN. THESE TYPE OF CRIMES
BY TRYING TO TAKE AWAY THE
PROFIT MOTIVE BY TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM FROM THE-
FROM THE- THE RECYCLER. CHOP
SHOPS- SIDE OF THE OPERATION-
AND- BY REQUIRING A CORE
RECYCLERS TO- VERIFY VEHICLE
OWNERSHIP OF BEFORE PURCHASE AND
TO PROHIBIT THEM FROM ACCEPTING
THAT FROM ANYONE OTHER THAN A
LICENSED ENTERPRISE OR THE OWNER
OF THE VEHICLE- WE ARE TRYING TO
MAKE IT TO TAKE AWAY THAT THAT
PROFIT MOTIVE- TO- DISINCENTIVE
VICE AND THESE TYPE OF CRIMES.
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE OF THE-
THE BELL IS A- RANDY PERRY WITH
THE ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE ON.
INNOVATION YOUR MUCH RICHER
MEMBERS RANDY PERRY WITH THE-
ALLIANCE PROBLEM INNOVATION HAS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER REPORTED THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR IS
ESTIMATED ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED
CATHOLIC CONVERTER THEFTS PER
MONTH RECENTLY I PERSONALLY AM A
VICTIM OF IT AND IT COST ME
ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO GET MINE DONE I CAN'T
IMAGINE. OF SOMEONE WHO'S ON A
LIMITED INCOME- HAVING TO BEAR
THAT EXPENSE OUT OF THE BLUE
WOULD NOT BUDGETED FOR- SO WE'RE
DOING WHATEVER WE CAN THEIR
SEVERAL BILLS OUT THERE THAT
WE'RE SUPPORTING. MORE WORKING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OTHERS
TO TRY AND- SURROUNDING THE
ISSUE. FORTUNATELY THERE IS AN
ISSUE THAT'S EVENTUALLY GOING TO
GO AWAY SINCE- TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE WHAT TO SELL ONLY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES SO IT WILL NOT BE A
CATHOLIC EMERGED UNTIL THEN.
NEED DO WE CAN THIS SEEMS LIKE A
REASONABLE APPROACH WE SUPPORTED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I BELIEVE- MISTER CHANG. WE
WANT TO. PRESENT AS A WITNESS.
THE BOARD MUST YES. THIS ON YES
I BELIEVE SO. YEAH YES SIR A
DISPATCHER MEMBERS TIM CHANG
WITH THE AUTO CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TRIPLE LAY- WE DO
SUPPORT THE BILL WE'VE SEEN. THE
SAME KINDS THE NUMBERS A TENFOLD
MORE THAN A TEN FOLD INCREASE IN
THE THAT NUMBER OF THEFTS OF
CATALYTIC CONVERTER SINCE TWENTY
NINETEEN THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHICH IS THE LAST YEAR WE
HAVE STATISTICS. BY OUR
ESTIMATES WE ESTIMATE THAT THIS
IS A TWO HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR
A YEAR PROBLEM HERE IN THE STATE
AND- WE'RE LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS
WE THINK THAT- YOU KNOW. IF
YOU'RE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE
INSURANCE YOU CAN GET SOME OF
THIS PAGE BUT IF YOU DON'T. THIS
IS A COSTLY REPAIR OF A THOUSAND
TO TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT'S
REAL MONEY FOR MY CALIFORNIANS.
WE URGE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
PRIMARY I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
ANY PRIMER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY. ADD ON THE NEED
TO IS- IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. ANYBODY
WANT TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT. ONE
OF ONE I HAD ON OPPOSITION THIS
GOES A LOT FASTER WITHOUT THE
PHONE LINES- SEEING NINE WANT TO
BRING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE
FOLKS MIGHT HAVE ON THE BILL.
AND WE ARE S. OKAY AFTER. YOUR
SUPPORT AND EXUBERANCE- WE'LL
GET TO THAT. YES START WEBER.
THANK YOU FOR THE VELOPARK I'M
HAPPY JUST ONE QUICK QUESTION
HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT- THE
CONVERTER WOULD BE- FROM THE
ACTUAL OWNER YEAH I MEAN THAT'S
A PROBLEM I THINK EVERYONE'S
TRYING TO CRACK THAT NUT- YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO- FIRST OF ALL I
SORT OF EMPHASIZE THAT- YOU KNOW
WE ARE PLANNING ON FURTHER
AMENDING THE BILL WITH THE
TICKET TO THE I. COMMITTEE
SUPPORT. ARM WE'D LIKE TO ADD A
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY THAT THE
OWNER OF PRODUCE- A COPY OF THE
TITLE OF THE VEHICLE FROM WHICH
THE CATHOLIC CONVERTERS WITH WAS
TAKEN FROM- YOU KNOW SO YEAH
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE STILL
THE LEGITIMATE QUESTION OF-
WHETHER THAT IS A- TRUTHFUL OR
FRAUDULENT REPRESENT
REPRESENTATION AS TO YOU KNOW
WHERE THAT CALYX. CONVERTER CAME
FROM BUT- RIGHT RIGHT WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO- ADD TO THE EXISTING
LAW AND TO YOU KNOW TO- REQUIRE
THAT THESE TYPE OF TRANSACTIONS
ONLY TAKE PLACE FROM THE-
RIGHTFUL OWNER OF THE VEHICLE-
FROM WHICH THINK THE CONVERTER
WAS TAKEN- NOW TO FURTHER
SUPPORT EXISTING LAW AS TO.
PRODUCING FALSE DOCUMENTS-
RECEIVING STOLEN PROPERTY SO.
GREAT WELL I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFT IS A HUGE ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S CLEAR WE NEED TO
DO MORE TO PREVENT IT MIGHT MY
OFFICE WE WERE CONSIDERING
INTEREST LEGISLATION AS WELL
UNTIL WE REALIZE THAT PLENTY OF
OTHER WERE ALREADY
DOING THAT- SO APPRECIATE YOU
FOR. RELIEVING THAT UP I DO
WANNA ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO NARROW THE TYPES
OF BUSINESSES FROM WHICH
SECONDHAND CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
MAY BE PURCHASED- BOTTOM
OTHERWISE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL- TODAY AS SOON AS WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU RAM I'LL GIVE
AND I THINK YOU'RE OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE WE ARE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. SO WITH THAT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON THE- TO I
REMEMBER SIX- FROM SOME MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AB. TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANNA
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AS A PRO AS A
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR
WORKING WITH US SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE THIS VEHICLE FORWARD AS WE
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING THE
MINIMUM NUMBER OF INSTRUCTIONAL
HOURS REQUIRED TO OBTAIN A
COSMOPROF COSMETOLOGY LICENSE.
THE BILL BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY WILL MAKE MINOR TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO CLEAN UP LANGUAGE OF
SB EIGHT OH THREE WHICH WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR. I WITH ME
TODAY IS ALISON RAINY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I MEETING
MEMBERS ALISON RAINY ON BEHALF
OF BELLUS ACADEMY AND JOHN PAUL
MITCHELL SCHOOLS WERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AS AMENDED. ONE AT
THANK YOU CHAIR AND CONSULTANTS
FOR THE CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD
AROUND THE HOURS. WE DO HOPE TO
CONTINUE THOSE BOTH WITH THE
BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY AND WITH YOUR
COLLEAGUES OVER IN THE SENATE.
I'M NOW THAT THE THOUSAND OUR
CURRICULUM HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED
IN TEXAS WE ARE STARTING TO DO
SURVEYS BOTH OF THE STUDENTS AND
THE SALONS AFTER THE FACT. AND
ARE SEEN SOME GAPS SO WE'VE MET
EXCUSE ME REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT THAT THOUSAND OUR PROGRAM
MEANS FOR STUDENTS AND BEING
ABLE TO STAY IN THIS PROFESSION
LONG TERM. SO THANK YOU AND ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I BELIEVE TO HAVE
EVAN QUARTER. WITH FBI SEE- IT
WAS ODD. MAIN WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. YEAH THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SEVEN QUARTER
ON BEHALF OF THE FUTURE THE
BEAUTY INDUSTRY COALITION WE
WERE ORIGINALLY OPPOSED TO THE
OUR INCREASE IN THE BILL. BUT
WITH THE AMENDMENTS WE WILL BE
GOING NEUTRAL AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK FROM YOU YOUR STAFF AND THE
AUTHOR ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION WANT TO ADD ON
. SEEING NONE ONE OF BRING BACK
TO COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. NO QUESTIONS NO
COMMENTS. WE ARE CLOSE MISTER
MAKE YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE GREAT THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR OF FOR
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
MOMENTUM FOR THE CONVERSATIONS.
THAT WE'VE HAD I UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THAT THIS BILL IS THE
RESULT OF CONCERNS RAISED BY
SOME COSMETOLOGY SCHOOLS
FOLLOWING CHANGES MADE THROUGH
MASTERS SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS.
WELL THE BILL WE ARE PASSING
TODAY WOOD- NO LONGER CONTRADICT
FOSSE CHANGES THIS COMMITTEE
MADE COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
SENATE REGARDS TO SCHOOL HOURS I
DO SUPPORT YOUR DESIRE TO KEEP
THE DISCUSSION OPENED WITH THIS
AMENDED VEHICLE AND INVITE YOU
TO KEEP THIS COMMITTEE ENGAGED
IN THAT PROCESS. AND WITH THAT
SAID- WHAT. WHEN THE TIME COMES
THE BILL WILL ENJOY MY
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU BOTH
BRIDGET. SO WITH THAT I DON'T
SEE ANY NON COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
HERE MISTER FLORA IF YOU'RE
READY FOR ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN. NO NO FORM
YET STILL WE'RE GETTING CLOSER
WE'RE GETTING AT. A YOU. THERE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS. I WOULD LIKE TO START
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
WE ARE HAPPY TO TAKE THE
COMMITTEE MINUTES SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT. AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN
WILL PERMIT THOSE WHO ARE
LICENSED TO CONDUCT MY MULLET
MOLECULAR TESTING FOR HUMAN
GENETICS. TO ALSO DO IT FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES THIS BILL
AUTHORIZES AN- ADULT WHO IS
RECEIVED APPROPRIATE TRAINING.
AS ACTED IN A STORY OF A-
FEDERAL CLIA WAIVER DIRECTOR. AN
ORDERING PHYSICIAN TO COULD
CONDUCT BOTH- ANTERIOR NASAL
SWAB WITH INDIVIDUALS BEING
TESTED. ARE UNABLE TO SELF SWAB.
WITH ME TODAY TO HELP TESTIFY
SINCE I THINK WE'VE GOT AN I
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
WE'VE GOT KELLY HIKES FROM. HE
LOOKS IN DOCTOR LYNN SILVER- SO
PLEASE. I THINK YOU MIGHT NEED A
PRESS PERFECT. THANK YOU ON. MY
NAME IS KELLY HIKES AND I WORK
FOR HELIX WHERE POPULATION
GENOMICS COMPANY WITH LOTS BASED
IN SAN DIEGO- OUR MILK OUR
CLINICAL MOLECULAR BIOLOGY
SCIENTIST BEEN DOING COKE IN
NINETEEN TAX ANOTHER MOLECULAR
TESTS. ON FOR TWO YEARS. THEIR
BREAD AND BUTTER WORK IS DOING
ON HUMAN GENOME SEQUENCING WHICH
IS ALSO A MOLECULAR TEST AND
THEY TRANSFERRED THEIR SKILLS TO
BE ABLE TO YOU DOYOU ARE
MOLECULAR TESTS FOR PATHOGENS WE
JUST LIKE TO SEE THAT.
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE I THINK
WE'VE NOT WITH EVERY OFFICE AND
SO. IN THE INTEREST OF TIME IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM AND WE ARE
JUST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- OF
DYLAN SILVER PEDIATRICIAN AND
DIRECTOR OF THE SAFELY OPENING
SCHOOLS PROJECT AT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE- DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS STATEWIDE OUGHT
TO INCREASE COVERT NINETEEN
RAPID TESTING. AND I THINK ALL
OF YOU KNOW THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF COPING NINETEEN ON
EDUCATION AND THE WELL BEING OF
OUR CHILDREN- TO DO SO WE'VE
WORKED TO OVERCOME THE MANY
BARRIERS TO INCREASING TESTING
AVAILABILITY FROM DATA SYSTEMS
TO HUMAN RESOURCES. AND THE
LATEST OMICRON SEARCH SOMETIMES
A QUARTER STAFF AND STUDENTS
WERE INFECTED IN SCHOOLS WOULD
CLOSE WITHOUT AT ACCESS TO
TESTING. ON OUR SCHOOLS
PERFORMED OVER FOUR MILLION
TESTS JUST THE LAST FEW MONTHS
AND TODAY THE NEW OMICRON BA TO
SIR JUST STARTING AND HOW THAT
WILL AFFECT OUR SCHOOLS- AND
OTHER INSTITUTIONS IS UNCERTAIN.
SO THROUGH BASICALLY ONE LESSON
WE'VE LEARNEDIT'S QUITE SIMPLY
TO BE READY- IN RECENT SURVEYS
MOST MOST REAFFIRM THEIR DESIRE
TO MAINTAIN THE OPTION OF
TESTING ON SITE AS PER. THAT
READING READINESS. SO MOST OF
YOU ARE PROBABLY ALREADY USED
RAPID TESTS NOW LICENSED FOR
HOME USE AND YOU KNOW HOW EASY
THEY ARE. THE STATE IS
DISTRIBUTING MILLIONS OF THEM UP
FIRST. NOW BUT FOR THE LARGE
SCALE TESTING IN SCHOOLS THIS IS
STILL CARRIED OUT UNDER THE-
CLIA WAIVER PROCESS. AND THAT
REQUIRES A TESTING BE DONE BY A
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL. ALTHOUGH
INTERPRETATIONS WERE FORTUNATELY
MADE ALLOWING SCHOOL STAFF TO
PERFORM THE TESTS THE BARRIERS
REMAINED FOR EXTENDING- TO TRAIN
PARENTS NON SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
COMMUNITY VOLUNTEER. HOURS TO DO
TWO THINGS EVEN WITH THESE VERY
SIMPLE METHODS SCHOOL NURSES ARE
IN SHORT SUPPLY AND TESTING
VENDORS. ENCOUNTER DIFFICULTIES
IN RECRUITING SUFFICIENT HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ESPECIALLY IN OUR
RURAL AREAS. MAKING IT DIFFICULT
TO SURGE- TESTING- TO INCREASE
TESTING DURING A SURGE OR TO
MAINTAIN A TRAINED CADRE. OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OR VOLUNTEERS.
AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN WILL
CORRECT THIS BARRIER ALLOWING
APPROPRIATELY TRAINED AND
SUPERVISED ADULTS. THE TEST IF
ONCE. AGAIN WE NEED TO SCALE UP
SCHOOL TESTING. USING THE SENT
TECH. WE CAN DO SO MORE QUICKLY
AND SIMPLE AND SIMPLY FROM
HUMBOLDT TO IMPERIAL. AND KEEP
OUR KIDS IN SCHOOL MORE SAFELY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- AND I DON'T SEE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION DO WE
HAVE IN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
NOPE. ANYBODY WANT TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT. IT'S CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF FIELDING GRIEVES ABOUT COM
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. STRONG SUPPORT FOR
AT MOVING DIAGNOSTIC TESTING
CAPACITY AND DIAGNOSTIC TESTING
SURGE CAPACITY FOR IT THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANKS SO MUCH. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRED WANTED THANK
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE FOR THE
WORK ON THIS BILL AND LIKE THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING REP
JUSTIN VANS ARE REPRESENT HELIX
AND ALSO HERE REPRESENTING THE
PROTECT US COALITION. ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEEDED ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE BRING
ABOUT A COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTSAND COLLEAGUES. YOU
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THING
NONE MISTER REISS YOUR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THIS RESPECT LAST
RIVAL. MY FAVORITE CLOTHES OTHER
THINK THE VICE CHAIR AND
SUPPORTERS FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL. IT MAKES SENSE TO
REVISIT LICENSING REQUIREMENTS
AND ENSURE THEIR CONSISTENT WITH
MODERN PRACTICES AND IN THE END
INNOVATIONS. SO WITH THE
ACCEPTED A MOMENTS I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND WILL
CALL VOTE WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANKS SO MUCH. NEXT UP WE'VE
GOT. MR GRUBER. SNEAK IN AND
WELL PLAYED SIR. I ALWAYS COME
IN THE BACK DOOR LIKE IT DID IN
THERE I DEFINITELY. THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST AB TWO EIGHT NINE FOUR
REQUIRES A LICENSE CONTRACTOR TO
FOR THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD OF THEIR WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLASSIFICATION
CODES ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
REQUIRES C. S. L. B. TO PUT THAT
INFORMATION ON THE INTERNET
WEBSITE CURRENTLY C. S. L. B.
LICENSE STATUS LOOKUP TOOL SHOWS
WHETHER OR NOT THE COMPANY IS
CARRYING A WORKERS COMPENSATION
INSURANCE POLICY BUT DOES NOT
INDICATE THE FOUR DIGIT WCC
CODE. ASSOCIATED WITH OBTAINING
THE POLICY SINCE RATES FOR
WORKERS COMPENSATION INSURANCE
VERY BASED ON THE FOUR DIGIT W.
C. C. CODE USED. WE HAVE
INTENTIONALLY MISCLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES TO RECEIVE LOWER
RATES. AS A RESULT SOME
CONTRACTORS PERFORMING WORK
WITHOUT OBTAINING PROPER. HE'S
IN THE ENTIRE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM. AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY FOUR WILL PROTECT
WORKERS BY REQUIRING LICENSE
CONTRACTORS PROVIDE INFORMATION
TO THE CSL BE. TO ENSURE
EMPLOYEES ARE PROPERLY INSURED
WILL PREVENT UNSCRUPULOUS
CONTRACTORS FROM PURCHASING.
LESS EXPENSIVE COVERAGE. WITH ME
TODAY IS KEEP DONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS KEEP DONE
HERE ON BEHALF THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF IRON WORKERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND JUST
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANYONE THIS
IS EXCUSE ME IN OPPOSITION SORRY
SEVERAL THE AND WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WE DON'T ANY PRIMER
WITNESSES GOOD SEEING ON ANY
ADDITIONAL IN THIS IS ONE ADAM
IN SUPPORT. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE BRING
BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND COLLEAGUES ALL EGGS
BUT A COUPLE MORE CALLS FOR A
QUORUM IF ANYONE'S WATCHING ON
TV. THE SOME NUMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SIR. I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
THIS BILL IS DOUBLE REFERRED TO
THE ASSEMBLY INSURANCE COMMITTEE
WHICH WILL TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT
THE PROVISIONS WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION- AND WHEN THE TIME
COMES WILL- HAVE A VOTE NOT BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANKS
SO MUCH. THANK YOU MR. SO NEXT
WE'LL MOVE ON I'M NUMBER FIFTEEN
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY FIVE BY
MISTER COOPER- ONCE AGAIN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BERS AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY FIVE SIX TO
INCREASE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS TAX ONE
THIS BILL REQUIRES AN ANNUAL
EXPENDITURE REPORT TO THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS TAX ONE. THE
LEGISLATURE. SIMPLY AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY FIVE REQUIRES
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. PROVIDED SPENDING
REPORT THE FUNDS IN THE YOUTH
EDUCATION PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION AND TREATMENT
ACCOUNT. BUT ACCORDING AN ANNUAL
EXPENSE REPORT IT ALLOWS
LEGISLATURE TO EXERCISE
OVERSIGHT OF SPENDING INCREASES
AND PROMOTES PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY
OF EXPENDITURES. THE BILL ALSO
CURRENTLY EXPAND THE CANNABIS
CONTROL PILLS PANEL I TO THE-
HELPER I PUT THROUGH THE
PROVISION IN ASKING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I DON'T HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ANYBODY WANT TO ADD
ON. IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM
ONE ADD ON. SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION NOBODY IS RUSHING TO
THE FRONT. SO WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YOU
COLLEAGUES WITH ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I DO NOT SEE ANY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THAT WE ARE JUST
CLICKING ON ALL CYLINDERS THANK
YOU AS A MEMBER COOPER FOR
TAKING SOME PROACTIVE STEPS. TO
IMPROVE THE LEGISLATURE IS
OVERSIGHT OF CANNABIS POLICY TAX
SPENDING. ANOTHER SEVERAL ISSUES
RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS AND I
TRUST THAT YOU'LL TAKE THOSE
INTO CONSIDERATION AND ACT
APPROPRIATELY IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE- DOING THAT. IN THE
MEANTIME WELL I WANT TO HAVE A
QUORUM I'LL BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL IN COMMITTEE TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
. SO I BELIEVE NEXT UP WE HAVE
MISTER O'DONNELL. WITH ITEM.
NUMBER EIGHT AB. TWENTY FOUR OH
SEVEN.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY WHENEVER
YOU ARE A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB TWO FOUR ZERO
SEVEN WHICH TIGHTENS THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE SALE OF
USED CATALYTIC CONVERTERS MAKING
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THIEVES TO
PROFIT. FROM SELLING STOLEN
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS AND THIS IS
A HUGE PROBLEM I'M SURE YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT IT IN YOUR OWN YOUR
OWN DISTRICTS AND THERE'S
ANOTHER FACTOR I. I HAVEN'T A
CAR WHERE IT NEEDS A NEW CATALOG
KOMMER WHAT IS STOLEN. BUT GUESS
WHAT THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS ONLY
AT THE DELER GET THAT CATALYTIC
CONVERTER REPLACED THAT'S
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY THOUGHTS
GOING ON OUT THERE. SO THERE'S A
LOT OF IMPACTS IT'S NOT JUST
HAVING IT STOLEN BUT IT'S IF YOU
NEED A NEW ONE AS WELL. KATELYN
CONVERTERS ARE MISSION
CONTROLLED I'VE DEVICES ON CARS
AND TRUCKS THE U. SEVERAL
COMPONENTS SUCH AS PRECIOUS
METALS LIKE PLATINUM. PALLADIUM
AT ROAD. RHODIUM TO CONVERT
TOXIC GASES INTO LESS. HARMFUL
EXHAUST UNFORTUNATELY INCREASES
IN THE PRICES OF THE PRECIOUS
METALS IN THESE DEVICES. HAS
RESULTED IN THEM BECOMING A
LUCRATIVE TARGET FOR THIEVES OF
WHICH YOU KNOW. ACCORDING TO THE
LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
THEFT OF CATALYTIC CONVERTERS IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
INCREASED BY 4100% IN TWENTY
TWENTY. AND HAS INCREASED
NATIONWIDE BY A STAGGERING
EIGHTY BY A STAGGERING ELEVEN
THE ELEVEN HUNDRED AND 71% SINCE
TWENTY NINETEEN. HELLO
CONVERTERS CAN BE REMOVED FROM
VEHICLES IN AS LITTLE AS TWO
MINUTES TWO MINUTES AND YOUR
CATALYTIC CONVERTER IS GONE.
DESPITE SIMILARITIES TO OTHER
SCRAP METALS THAT ARE FREQUENTLY
STOLEN AND OFFERED TO RECYCLERS
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS SALES DO
NOT HAVE THE SAME ANTI THEFT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AS THESE
OTHER MODELS THERE AFTER THE
METALS IN THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER NOT JUST THE CONVERTER
BECAUSE THOSE METALS ARE SO
VALUABLE SO PRECIOUS. AB TWENTY
FOUR OH SEVEN ELIMINATES THESE
INCONSISTENCIES BY REQUIRING
CORPS RECYCLERS TO REPORT
INFORMATION ABOUT SALES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IF TO REPORT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OBTAIN THE
THUMBPRINT OF THE SELLERS AND
REQUEST TO RECEIVE NOTIFICATIONS
FROM A THEFT ALERT SYSTEM. THESE
REQUIREMENTS HAVE SHOWN BY THE
NATIONAL HAVE TO HAVE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN SHOWN BY THE NATIONAL
INSURANCE CRIME BUREAU TO REDUCE
METAL THEFTS AND WILL DO THE
SAME FOR CATALYTIC CONVERTERS-
COPPER THERE'S OTHER PRECIOUS
METALS- IF YOU GO BISON. AND
GENERATING STATIONS THE LEADERS
SAY THE OVERSIGHT OTHERS A NO
COPPER IN THIS GENERATING
STATION BECAUSE COPPER IS VERY
VALUABLE SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS ESTABLISH THE- THE SAME
PROTOCOLS. OR FOR CATHOLIC
CONVERTER METALS AS THERE ARE
FOR MANY OTHER METALS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HERE TO
TESTIFY IS TIM CHANG WITH THE
AUTOMOBILE CLUB OF SALAS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THERE IS
THANK YOU FOR. RIGHT YEAH MR CHU
AND MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THAT
TIM CHANG FOR THE AUTO CLUB OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AGAIN- SINCE
THIS IS THE SECOND DECK
CATALYTIC CONVERTER BILL I WON'T
REPEAT MY PRIOR TESTIMONY BUT I
WANTED TO ADD ON- SOMETHING OF
THAT ASSEMBLY MINNA DONALD SAID
WHILE IT'S BEEN WELL IT'S EASY
TO STEAL A CATALYTIC CONVERTER
MAY TAKE YOU KNOW SECONDS TWO
MINUTES- DEPENDING ON THE SKILL
OF THE FEVER THERE COULD BE
SECONDARY DAMAGE THAT OCCURS TWO
VEHICLES WHICH OFTEN- RAISES THE
COST OF- OF REPAIR- FURTHER WITH
THE CURRENT SUPPLIES TO
SHORTAGES- OBTAINING A NEW
CATERPILLAR CONVERTER FOR YOUR
VEHICLE CAN BE A SOMETIMES
LENGTHY. PROCESS WHICH FURTHER
ADDS THE INCONVENIENCE OF
VICTIMS AND WE URGE ADVISED VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WHO WANT TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
MISTER MEMBERS RANDY PERRY WITH
THE ALLIANCE FROM OF INNOVATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE ONE OF
BRING BACK TO COLLEGE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THEY HAVE.
YEAH BUT WEBER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS BILL- I HAD A
QUESTION AROUND THE THUMB PRINT
REQUIREMENTS I'M IS THERE ANYONE
WHO IS EXEMPT FROM THAT I DIDN'T
SEE THAT IN YOUR BILL- NO BUT
WE'RE ALWAYS WILLING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS IF SOME PERSONS
SHOULD BE EXEMPT. OKAY BUT I
THINK WE WANT TO- APPLY THE BILL
EQUITABLE FASHION AS WELL RIGHT
NOW I'M I KNOW THAT EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES JUNK DEALERS ARE
RECYCLERS TO OBTAIN THAT BUT
THEY DO- CARVE OUT- AUTOMOBILE
DISMANTLES AND SOME OTHER PEOPLE
AS WELL AND SO. I JUST WONDERING
IF YOUR BILL IS DOING THAT THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAVE JUST IN
GENERAL ABOUT THEM PRINCE- IS
THERE ANY SECURITY REQUIREMENT
FOR THE ACTUAL PLACE THAT'S OR
THE DEALER OR- WHO'S HOLDING
THESE TEMPERANCE- A NOT THAT I'M
AWARE OF AT THIS TIME BUT THAT'S
A CONVERSATION WE CAN HAVE ON A
GO FORWARD BASIS FOR SURE
BECAUSE THERE SHOULD BE.
SECURITY AROUND THE- THE
THUMBPRINTS YET A LOT OF
SECURITY- WHETHER IT'S A HARD
COPY OR IF IT'S JUST SOMETHING
THAT THEY'RE KEEPING ON THEIR
COMPUTER WITH ALL OF THE ACT.
CYBER ATTACKS THAT WE'VE THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING SO- I
DEFINITELY THINK THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE MORE CONVERSATIONS AROUND
PLEDGING TO QUESTION BOTH OF
THEM. YEAH THANK YOU. FIGURE
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE IT'S
ASTRONOMICAL MISTER PRITCHETT
THAT THANK YOU US ON A MEMBER
DONALD. AS AS AS YOU RIGHTLY
SAID WE MUST DO MORE TO CURB
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFTS. IN
CALIFORNIA- I APPRECIATE THE-
QUESTIONS FROM DOCTOR WEBER I DO
WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER. WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT THE
THUMBPRINT REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT
OVERLY BURDENSOME ON LEGITIMATE
BUSINESSES- I THINK SOMEBODY
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER- POSSIBLY
EXEMPTING. OUR AUTOMOBILE THIS
METALLERS CORE RECYCLERS MOTOR
VEHICLE DEALERS AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR DEALER'S SOMETHING TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT- SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THOSE. ISSUES AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY ONCE
REFORM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH VERSION. ONE MORE BNP
MEMBER AND WE CAN VOTE ALL DAY
WE CAN JUST DEVOTE UNTIL WE'RE
DONE VOTE IN. LOTS OF ARE YOU
BRING COMMITTEE TO VOTE. WE
HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF VOTES YET
TODAY. BUT WITH THAT I SEE
MISTER DALY. WITH ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB TWENTY SIX ELEVEN READY
WHEN YOU ARE SIR. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- THIS BILL
SIMPLY PROVIDES A STANDARD
DEFINITION FOR A FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESS IN OUR STATE. WHAT'S
THAT DEFINITION IN STATUTE.
ACCORDING TO THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESSES GENERATE 57% OF THE
NATION'S GROSS DOMESTIC PRODUCT
. EMPLOYS 63% OF THE WORK FORCE
AND CREATE 75% OF ALL NEW JOBS.
GRADING STANDARD DEFINITION WILL
PROVIDE CLARITY FOR POLICYMAKERS
WHEN MAKING ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
DECISIONS SUCH AS TAX POLICIES
GRANT PROGRAMS AND EMPLOYEE
TRAINING INCENTIVES. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IS DENNIS ALL BIONDI
REPRESENTING THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED DENNIS
I'LL BE ON THE RIBS IN THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ISSUE OF
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE YOU
HERE IN THIS BILL WE HAVE AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- ARTICULATED
FAMILY BUSINESSES ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE LOCATED WITHIN YOUR
COMMUNITIES THEY SUPPORT THE
BASEBALL TEAMS IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY THEY HIRE US IT'S BEEN
PROVEN ELEVATING WOMEN TO A
POSITIONS OF. AUTHORITY AND THE
CITY SUITE OFFICES AT A MUCH
HIGHER RATE AND THE MORE
PHILANTHROPIC- IDENTIFYING A
DEFINITION WILL HELP BUT ONE
DEFINITION ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR BOTH THE STATE AS
WELL AS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL. NUMBER
ONE IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE
ANY WITNESSES- WHO WANT TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. SEEING NONE WANT TO
BRING IT BACK TO COLLEGE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ABOUT THIS
VERY GOOD BILL. I WANNA
PREJUDICE AND WAS THINKING OF
THIS VERY GOOD BILL GOING ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS ARE GONNA
PREJUDICES OKAY IN THIS CASE
YEAH ONLY IN THIS CASE IN THIS
CASE DOES IT WASN'T. UNTIL IT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR- I
THINK IT- THE BILL IS SIMPLE AND
FOCUSED AND SPEAKS FOR ITSELF
AND I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER DALY CALIFORNIA FAMILY
OWNED BUSINESSES ARE STAPLES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND ARE
DESERVING OF RECOGNITION IN OUR
STATE LAWS I DO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SPECIFY HOW THE DISH DEFINITION
SHOULD BE UTILIZED- BUT AM HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY ONCE
WE HAVE A QUORUM OF WHICH WE
ARE. ONE MEMBER AWAY FROM JUST
ONE GOOD JUST ONE MEMBER. JUST
ONE- NO. WELL YEAH EXACTLY JUST
THIS ONE. WE GOT ANOTHER OFFER
THOUGH THANK YOU MISTER DAY WE
WILL HAVE A VOTE AS SOON AS WE
GET THAT ONE THAT ARMY OF ONE TO
JOIN US YOU DESERVE A QUORUM I
THANK YOU SIR I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU. THANK YOU ARE A GENTLEMAN
AND A SCHOLAR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH. READY WHEN YOU ARE ON
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT. JUST TO GIVE
YOU A HEADS UP WE ARE ONE MEMBER
AWAY FROM A QUORUM. JUST ONE. ON. GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT. WHEN VOTERS
SUPPORTED PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR. THEY DID ON THE PREMISE
THAT THE INDUSTRY WOULD BE
BALANCED. CONSUMER DESIRE WITH
PUBLIC SAFETY SIMILAR TO OTHER
INDUSTRIES LIKE ALCOHOL.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT BALANCE
WASN'T EXECUTED IN THE
SUSTAINABLE. OR COMPELLING WAY.
AS A RESULT OF THIS LIGHT FOOTED
APPROACH AN UNINTENDED UNTESTED
AND UNREGULATED MARKET NOW EXIST
IN A WAY THAT EVEN BEFORE THE
PASSING OF PROP SIXTY FOUR. WE
WOULD LIKE AN EXAMPLE OF THIS IN
DECEMBER TO DINO COUNTY IN MY
DISTRICT ALONE. THERE'S BEEN A
2100% INCREASE IN THE SEIZURES
OF ILLEGAL MARIJUANA PLANTS
SINCE THE PASSING OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR. AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT. BUT CREATE A GRADUATION
IN THE CIVIL PENALTY STRUCTURE
FOR UNLICENSED CANNABIS ACTIVITY
. PENALTIES WILL BE TIED TO THE
SIZE IN THE SCALE OF THE ONLINE
UNLICENSED CANNABIS OPERATIONS
WITH A NUMBER OF PLANTS. NUMBER
OF PREVIOUS INFRACTIONS. AMOUNT
OF PRODUCT IN OTHER EXTENUATING
FACTORS TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHEN
ASSESSING THE FINE. THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA LET THE VOICES BE
HEARD IN CHOSE TO DECRIMINALIZE
CANNABIS. I SUPPORTED THEIR
CHOICE. HOWEVER THEY DID NOT ASK
FOR A RAMPANT CULTIVATION AND IN
THE LEGAL MARKET SUCKING UP
RESOURCES DESTROYING THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND PUTTING OUR
COMMUNITIES AT RISK. AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE MISTER BRAD
JENSEN YES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND IF THE KEYS HERE. ONE
AMBER. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS ON
RED JENSEN I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY THE
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT. WE'VE BROUGHT THIS
MEASURE BEFORE YOU FOR- TO
CONSIDER I GRADUATED CIVIL
PENALTY- STRUCTURE FOR ILLEGAL
CANNABIS. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH HAS MENTIONED WE'VE SEEN
AN EXPLOSION OF ILLEGAL CANNABIS
FARMING ACROSS THE MOJAVE
DESERT. WE ESTIMATE HAVING AT
LEAST THIRTEEN HUNDRED FARMS IN
OUR COUNTY ALONE SOME ESTIMATES
RANGE AS HIGH AS TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED. THIS CAUSES ANUMEROUS
SET OF PROBLEMS FOR US AND
DEALING WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
CLEANUP- LAWLESSNESS WATER THEFT
AND SO FORTH. WE BELIEVE THAT
HAVING A GRADUATED CIVILS CIVIL
PENALTY STRUCTURE IS VERY GOOD
FOR THE LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET
WHICH WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF.
WE THINK THAT THAT THE LARGER
THE GROW THE MORE PLANTS THAT
YOU'RE CULTIVATING YOU SHOULD
PAY TO HAVE YOUR FINE. AND BY
ELIMINATING THEM- WE ARE
SUPPORTING LAW ABIDING CITIZENS
WHO ARE ENGAGED IN LEGAL
CANNABIS.WHO PAY TAXES WHO PULL
PERMITS AND WHO FOLLOW PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODES SO WE
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I DON'T
HAVE ANY ON MY SHEET. I DON'T
SEE ANY ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION WHO WANT TO ADD ON
. STILL NOT SEEING ANY OR BRING
BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. WHY A BUNCH THIS
MORNING. THAT'S A TESTAMENT TO
THE GOOD BILLS THAT WERE-
STUDENT ART WEBER I JINXED YOU I
APOLOGIZE. GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- I THINK WE'RE
PROBABLY ALL AWARE OF. SOME OF
THE- AND INTENDED CONSEQUENCES
OF YOU KNOW THE LEGALIZATION OF
MARIJUANA WITH YOU HAVING LARGE-
MANUFACTURERS OR OR FARMS
GROWING ILLEGAL MARIJUANA. I'M I
THINK ONE OF MY CONCERNS WITH
YOUR BILL- IS. THAT YOU GO DOWN
TO SIX PLANTS. BECAUSE TO ME
THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE SOMEONE
WHO IS. WE ARE TRYING TO GO
AFTER WHO YOU SHOULD BE TRYING
TO GO AFTER THEY'RE NOT A BIG
PLAYER IF YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO
ONLY HAS SIX PLANTS. AND SO TO-
START INCREASING THEIR FINES-
FOR SOMEONE WHO'S PROBABLY LIKE
LOW INCOME VERY SMALL PLAYER IN
THIS GAME IS. IS A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNING FOR ME SO IS THERE
ANY PARTICULAR REASON WHY YOU
WENT SOLO. IN ORDER FOR
TOMORROW. LIKE AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT IS BASED ON THE
COUNTIES FEE STRUCTURE WHICH WAS
ENACTED AN ORDINANCE LAST AUGUST
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE- I THINK
THAT I AGREE WITH YOU I THINK
THAT THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
TO GO AFTER THE BIG FISH NOT THE
LITTLE GUY- AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S AN OPEN CONVERSATION
MOVING FORWARD AND I'LL DEFER TO
THE AUTHOR OF COURSE BUT- I
THINK THAT'S PART OF A SOMETHING
WE COULD REDUCE. THE REASON TO
GO TO SIX WELL PLANTS IZLE
CURRENT LAW SAYS YOU CAN HAVE
SIX INDIVIDUALS WE HAVE TO WORK
THAT WAY BEFORE BUT I'M NOT
AFTER. I'M I'M SORRY CAN YOU SAY
THAT AGAIN IT. THE CURRENT LAW
SAYS YOU HAVE TO HAVE UP TO SIX
PLANTS IS CURRENT LAW THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL GOING FORWARD WE'RE NOT
AFTER THE LITTLE ONES IN THE I
DON'T THINK ANY DA IN THE STATE.
WOULD HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE ONES
THAT HAVE HUNDREDS THOUSANDS OF
PLANTS. RIGHT I GUESS MY CONCERN
IS WHEN YOU ACTUALLY PUT IT IN
HERE. THEN THE OPPORTUNITY IS
AVAILABLE TO GO AFTER SOMEONE.
WITH ONLY SIX OR SEVEN PLAN BUT
I THINK WITH THE LEADS COUNCILS
LANGUAGE IT HAD TO BE PUT IN
THERE AT SIX ONE. I DO JUST ONE
COMMENT THAT THIS BILL WILL BE
GOING TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE-
WHERE WHERE A LOT OF THESE. BIG
QUESTIONS CAN ALSO BE EVALUATED
. I'M THEN I AM GOING TO STAY
OFF JUST TO SEE WHAT- HAPPENED
IMAGES DUE TO SHERRY COMMITTEE.
ON BECAUSE I THINK GOING DOWN SO
LOW IS JUST GOING AFTER THIS
THAT THE SMALL FISH WHEN WE
REALLY REALLY NEED TO BE GOING
AFTER. THE BIG FISH THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE REALLY REALLY PROFITING
FROM THIS ILLEGAL ACTIVITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR WHETHER
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. THING
ON SOME MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE A RESHAPE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AND I DEFINITELY THINK WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS MORE
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY THAN WE'D
LIKE- AND UNDERSTAND THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON LICENSEES ON
CONSUMERS IN THE REGULATORY
SCHEME OVERALL- IF ADDITIONAL
PENALTIES WOULD BE HELPFUL IN
THAT REGARD I AM SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT AS I JUST MENTIONED THE
BILL WILL ALSO GO TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE NEXT. WHERE
THE AMOUNTS IN THE NATURE OF THE
PENALTIES- I'M SURE WILL BE
DISCUSSED FURTHER- WHEN WE HAVE
. ONE MORE MEMBER. OF THE
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA LOSE ONE.
OKAY THIS IS THE DAY. THAT I GOT
NERVOUS HE HAS JUST ONE MORE
MEMBER WE WILL HAVE A VOTE ON
THIS BILL. AND ALL THE OTHER
BILLS HAVE BEEN PRESENTED TODAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WHEN
YOU GET A QUORUM LOCK THE DOORS
THANK YOU THEY EXACTLY RIGHT
EXACTLY RIGHT WILL DO THANK YOU
SOME MEMBER SMITH- AND NOW WE
STILL DON'T HAVE. ONE MEMBER BUT
WE HAVE A SET BUT WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER PRESENTER PERMITS ON A
RECALL THEIR OWN- WITH AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SIX.
MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS. FIRST
I'D IKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
AND I WILL BE TAKING ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX WILL
PROHIBITORY A- REVOKING OR
SUSPENDING THE MEDICAL LICENSE
OF A PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON. FOR
PROVIDING SAFE AND LEGAL
ABORTION CARE TO PATIENTS AND
CALIFORNIA OR IN OTHER STATES.
TWENTY SIX STATES ARE ACTIVELY
SEEKING TO BAN ABORTION. WITH
MANY STATES AUTHORIZING THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO TAKE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AGAINST THE
ABORTION PROVIDER. AS A
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM STATE
CALIFORNIA IS LIKELY TO BE A
DESTINATION FOR MILLIONS OF
PREGNANT PEOPLE SEEKING ABORTION
CARE THAT THEY CANNOT GET IN
THEIR OWN STATE. THIS
LEGISLATION PREVENTS THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA FROM
REVOKING OR SUSPENDING A LICENSE
FOR PROVIDING LAWFUL ABORTION.
PATIENTS SEEKING CARE FROM
CALIFORNIA PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX IS DR
DANIEL GROSSMAN A PROFESSOR OF
OPS THE TETRIS OFF OFF THE TOP
TRICKS AND GYNECOLOGY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE HE DIRECTS A
RESEARCH PROGRAM CALLING CALLED
ADVANCING NEW STANDARDS IN
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. THANK YOU
DOCTOR. THANK YOU I'M AS A
PRACTICING OBGYN I HAVE WORKED
IN COUNTRIES WHERE ABORTION IS
ILLEGAL OR RESTRICTED AND I'VE
SEEN FIRST HAND HOW PREGNANT
PEOPLE- HAVE TO SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES OF UNSAFE ABORTIONS
SOMETIMES PAYING WITH THEIR
LIVES. I NEVER THOUGHT THAT I
WOULD SEE THE DAY- WHEN ABORTION
CARE WOULD BE ILLEGAL HERE IN
THE U. S. STATE BUT THAT DAY HAS
ALREADY ARRIVED HERE IN TEXAS-
AND AS WE JUST HEARD OF IT'S
LIKELY WET THAT WITH ROE VERSUS
WADE BEING UNDERMINED IN THE
VERY NEAR FUTURE. THAT MAY
HAPPEN IN POTENTIALLY HALF OF
THE STATES IN THE U. S. AS A
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM STATE- WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. AND THAT IS A
RESPONSIBILITY THAT MY FELLOW
PHYSICIAN ABORTION PROVIDERS
TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY WE CANNOT
SIT IDLY BY- AS WE SEE PEOPLE'S
RIGHTS TAKEN AWAY IN OTHER
STATES. PUTTING THEIR HEALTH AT
RISK WHEN WE HAVE THE SKILLS AND
TOOLS TO HELP THEM. IF A PATIENT
IN A STATE WITH SEVERE
RESTRICTIONS SEEKS OUT MY HELP
AND TO OBTAIN SAFE ABORTION CARE
I WOULD FEEL COMPELLED TO HELP
THEM- FOR EXAMPLE A PATIENT MAY
TRAVEL HERE TO CALIFORNIA TO
OBTAIN ABORTION CARE HERE. THEY
MAY TRAVEL HERE TO RECEIVE
MEDICATIONS TO START THE
ABORTION WHICH WOULD THEN BE
COMPLETED IN THEIR HOME STATE OR
THEY MAY SEEK OUT- TELEHEALTH
SERVICES TO OBTAIN A MEDICATION
ABORTION PER CALIFORNIA
PROVIDER. AND DESPITE MY GOOD
INTENTIONS TO HELP PEOPLE
NEEDING ABORTION CARE IN THE
STATE'S I UNDERSTAND THAT I
WOULD FACE A NUMBER OF LEGAL
RISKS- BY PROVIDING THE CARE
THAT I'VE OUTLINED TO A PATIENT.
FROM A STATE THAT HAS BANNED
ABORTION INCLUDING POTENTIAL
CIVIL AND CRIMINAL CRIMINAL
PENALTIES AS WELL AS THE
POSSIBILITY OF LOSING MY
LICENSE. AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIX WOULD HELP ADDRESS AT LEAST
THIS LAST POINT- BY ENSURING
THAT MY MEDICAL LICENSE WOULD
NOT BE SUSPENDED OR REVOKED.
BECAUSE OF THE WASHING CARE THAT
I PROVIDED THAT IS OTHERWISE
LEGAL AND SAFE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE MUST STAND FIRM
AGAINST THE CHILLING EFFECT THAT
THESE RESTRICTIVE LAWS WILL
HAVE. AND STATE CLEARLY THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICIAN PROVIDE
SAFE. CARE THAT IS LEGAL HERE
WILL NOT BE PUNISHED EVEN IF THE
PATIENT IS A RESIDENT OF A STATE
WITH SEVERE RESTRICTIONS. A KEY
COMPONENT OF THIS PROTECTION
SAFEGUARDING OUR MEDICAL LICENSE. THANK YOU DR GROSSMAN WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN-
SUPPORT. HELLO MOLLY ROBESON
WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA WERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. C. NUMBERING BACK
TO COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. DR WEBER. I JUST
WANNA THANK ON MY COLLEAGUES FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
MY OTHER COLLEAGUE FOR RIPPING
HERE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY FOR
THOSE OF US WHO ARE TRAINED AND
PROVIDE THIS SERVICE FOR
PATIENTS OUT YOU KNOW WE KNOW
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT- FOR THEIR
OVERALL WELL BEING FOR THE
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND TO HAVE
THIS THIS NOT ON OUR BACKS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT LOSING OUR
MEDICAL LICENSE FOR DOING WHAT'S
RIGHT IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
CRITICAL ON TO OUR PRACTICE-
INTO OUR INDIVIDUAL WELL BEING
SO. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PRESENTING THIS I WILL
DEFINITELY BE SUPPORTING AND-
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
I'M ANSWER QUESTIONS. FOR MEMBER
CALDERON YOU ARE CLOSE I THINK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
NAY VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
OUR I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AGREE- THAT SUPPORTING PROVIDERS
OF REPRODUCTIVE CARE IS
ESSENTIAL- AND WITH THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS BEING TAKEN
IN COMMITTEE TODAY I'M- HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. WE NOW WE
WENT FROM ONE WE NOW NEED TO.
MEMBERS BECAUSE ONE LEFT. SO
WE'RE- GOING THE WRONG DIRECTION
BUT ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL
HAVE A VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS A MEMBER THANK YOU MR. THANK
YOU. NOW IT'S ONLY TO SUNNY EVEN
WHAT I WAS I WAS COUNTY GIPSON
IS ALWAYS HERE. IS AND ALWAYS
CLOSE. YOUR MEGA YOU ARE
APPRECIATED HE IT. THE NOW FOR
WE HAVE NO AUTHORS AND NOT
ENOUGH MEMBERS ARE VOTE THE
ELEMENTS WERE. WHEN WE'RE NOT
DOING WELL AT ALL- IF IT'S OLY
NUMBER CARILLO OR IS A MEMBER
KALRA. DON'T WANT THEIR BILLS TO
DIE. THEY WILL COME PRESENT THEM
THE MOST CAN'T ACTUALLY DIE
BECAUSE WE DON'T A QUORUM. SO WE
CAN ACTUALLY VOTE. YEAH THEY
JUST HANG ON HANG ON. IT'S GOT
THIS GOT DARK
-
HOW MANY HOW MANY MINUTES.
WE'RE BACK TO ONE YOU ALL WERE
BACK NEEDING ONE MORE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ACTUALLY DO OUR JOBS.
WHICH I WOULD APPRECIATE. HENCE. WE ARE WE ARE GETTING CREATIVE
TO TRY TO INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO
SHOW UP. THE BABY WHO THAT MIGHT
THAT'S IT YEAH I WAS SO SORRY
ONE MORE. THE ONLY ONE MORE WE
GET SO MUCH WORK DONE.
HEY. ALL RIGHT WE GOT OFF THERE
WAS ONLY ONE MORE COMMITTEE
MEMBER FOR A QUORUM BUT AT LEAST
WE GOT OFF THEIR PHONE NUMBER
KALRA AGENDA ITEM THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR READY
WHEN YOU ARE. IN SIR. THANK YOU
OF HIS SHARE MEMBERS. LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE STAFF WILL WORK WITH
MY OFFICE. AND I'LL BE ACCEPTING
OF THE A COMMITMENTS ON THE BILL
. AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR
WOULD PERMIT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL TO ISSUE
CANNABIS HEARING LICENSES TO
ALLOW LICENSE USED TO SERVE
CANNABIS OR CANNABIS PRODUCTS. A
SUMMER CAR I APOLOGIZE I'M
INTERVIEW FOR ONE SECOND CAN
SOMEBODY GO OUT AND GET MISTER
GIBSON TO MISTER LEE MISTER
GIBSON THAT MR LEE WHERE IS MR
LEE. THANK GOODNESS WHERE IS
BECAUSE I WAS A QUORUM YET
BEFORE I GONZALEZ I DIDN'T I
DIDN'T I MEAN THREE COMMITTEES
THIS MORNING. I GET. IT ARE I WE
GOT TEN WE'RE GONNA- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BERMAN HERE. LARA HERE
LIMB. CHEN. CUNNINGHAM DALY FONG
GIPSON GRAYSON IRWIN LEAVE IT
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN. SALAS
HANG WEBER. HELLO YEAH WE HAVE A
QUORUM THE SUN OVER CAR IF YOU
LIKE TO CONTINUE WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION SIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AS I INDICATED APPRECIATE
THE ACT PRETTY AMENDMENTS WILL
BE ACCEPTING AB TWENTY FORTY
FOUR PERMIT THE DEPARTMENT
ACCOUNTED CONTROL ISSUE CAMPUS
CARRY LICENSES TO ALLOW
LICENSEES TO SERVE CANNABIS OR
CANNABIS PRODUCTS. A PRIVATE
EVENTS. DESPITE WITH
RECREATIONAL CANNABIS
CONSUMPTIONBECOMING AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCE FOR VISITORS AND
RESIDENTS ALIKE. THE STATE HAS
YET TO REGULATE CANNABIS
CATERING AND HOTELS AND
THROUGHOUT THE TRAVEL INDUSTRY.
UNDER EXISTING LAW CANNABIS
RETAILERS CAN BE ISSUES STATE
TEMPORARY EVENT LICENSES
LICENSES. ALLOW FOR ON SITE
CANNABIS SALES CONSUMPTION
WITHIN A LIMITED SET OF VENUES.
AND UNDER SPECIFIC RESTRICTIONS
BY THE STATE. HOWEVER THESE
LICENSES DO NOT CURRENTLY COVER
SITUATIONS IN WHICH AN EVENT
HOST PRE PAYS FOR CANNABIS AND
CANNABIS PRODUCTS. PROVIDED FREE
OF CHARGE MOVING YES. BY
CREATING THESE CATERING LICENSES
AB TWENTY FORTY FOUR. WE'LL
CREATE A REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT
TO HELP INSURERS GREATER SAFETY
AND OVERSIGHT OF CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION. GATHERINGS SUCH AS
WEDDINGS AND WELLNESS RETREATS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
JERRED KILOH PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION. AND BRIAN
APPLEGARTH FOUNDER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS TOURISM
ASSOCIATION. RIGHT RIGHT ON YOUR. I THINK YOU MIGHT NEED TO HIT
THE BUTTON A- BIRD I GUESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BRIAN APPLEGARTH FOUNDER OF THE
CANNABIS TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
FORMALLY KNOWN AS THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS TOURISM ASSOCIATION FOR
UNITED VOICE OF CAMPUS TRAVEL.
COSPONSOR OF AB TWENTY FORTY
FOUR. PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA'S TRAVEL INDUSTRY WAS
ONE OF THE LARGEST ECONOMIC
DRIVERS OF OUR STATE ACCORDING
TO DEAN RUNYAN ASSOCIATES IN
TWENTY NINETEEN MORE THAN ONE
POINT TWO MILLION CALIFORNIA
WORKERS EARN THEIR LIVELIHOOD
AND HOSPITALITY. AND VISITORS
SPENT A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
BILLION ANNUALLY GENERATING
TWELVE POINT THREE BILLION IN
STATE AND LOCAL TAX REVENUES.
THEN CAME TWENTY TWENTY WITH THE
PANDEMIC. AND A BOOMING
CALIFORNIA TRAVELING SHE WAS
DEVASTATED MORE THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY WORKERS LOST THEIR JOBS
IN THE STATE LOST SEVENTY EIGHT
POINT EIGHT BILLION IN VISITOR
SPENDING IN TWENTY TWENTY A
FIFTY FOUR POINT 5% DECLINE FROM
THE YEAR PRIOR. I CANNABIS
CATERING LICENSE OFFERS AN
OPPORTUNITY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DRIVE SAFETY IN THE VISITOR
ECONOMY DIFFERENTIATION IN
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL AND
ALTERNATELY SUPPORT RECOVERY
FROM THE PANDEMIC FOR THE TRAVEL
INDUSTRY. THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY TODAY
REPESENTS APPROXIMATELY FOUR
BILLION IN ANNUAL SALES EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION IN STATE TAXES
THREE HUNDRED MILLION LOCAL
TAXES AND HAS CREATED AN
ESTIMATED A HUNDRED THOUSAND
JOBS. IN- A CALIFORNIA CANNABIS-
GOT THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
CATERING LICENSE IS NEEDED TODAY
AND AS OUTLINED IN AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY FOUR IT'S PROPOSED
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF CAMPUS
CONTROL ME ISSUE STATE CATER
LICENSE AT AUTHORIZES THE
LICENSEE TO SERVE CANNABIS AT A
PRIVATE EVENT. APPROVED BY A
LOCAL JURISDICTION FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ALLOWING EVENT
ATTENDEES TO CONSUME CANNABIS.
CANNABIS CARING LICENSE WILL
DRIVE TAX REVENUE EXPAND RETAIL
OUTLETS AND COMBAT THE ILLICIT
MARKET WHILE CREATING A NEW AND
UNIQUE TOOL TO SUPPORT THE
REBOUND OR RECOVERY OF
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL IN THE HOTEL
INDUSTRY- IT'LL INCREASE SAFETY
AND MITIGATE RISK. AND OFFER A
COMPLIANT AND CLEAR INTEGRATION
PATHWAY FOR HOTELS ATTRACTIONS
WEDDING PLANNERS AND WELLNESS
RETREATS. AND OTHER PRIVATE
GATHERING VENUES OF ALL KINDS.
THAT ARE PART OF THE TRAVEL
ECOSYSTEM OF CALIFORNIA. IN
CLOSING THE CANNABIS TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION REQUEST COMMITTEE
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY FORTY
FOUR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IF MY NAME IS CHAIRED KYLO
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
CAMPUS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION-
WE'VE COME TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
AS A RETAILER IN THE CANNABIS
SPACE FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS OF
MYSELF- WE'VE BEEN SEEING THIS
ACTIVITY PRE TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
AND POST TWENTY EIGHTEEN PROP
SIXTY FOUR. THAT TIVITY IS
BRINGING TOGETHER TAURUS IT'S
BRING TOGETHER FAMILIES IS
BRINGING TOGETHER A LOT OF.
PRIVATE EVENTS THE PRIDE EVENTS
ARE ALSO ALREADY HAVING THESE
KINDS OF ACTIVITIES HAPPEN. AND
WHAT WE'RETRYING TO DO HERE IN
THIS BILL IS GIVE A PLACE FOR
REGULATION GIVE A PLACE FOR
EDUCATION AND EVENT. FOR THE U.
AREN'T THE DRUNK UNCLE AT A
WEDDING. YOU WE'RE GIVING THESE
OPPORTUNITIES NOW FOR SOMEONE TO
TAKE ON THE LIABILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY AWAY FROM MAYBE A
HOTEL. THAT WOULD WANT TO HAVE
SOME INSURANCE TO COVER ANY SORT
OF THESE LIABILITIES WE'RE
GIVING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO ASSESS
RISK. AND IN THE ASSESSMENT OF
RISK THEY CAN HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE THIS LICENSE
A PLACE INSIDE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE 75% OF MOST
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
DON'T OFFER ANY SORT OF ACCESS
TO LEGAL RETAIL CANNABIS. WE
NEED AN OPPORTUNITY TO ALLOW
THIS KIND OF EVENTS AND THESE
KINDS OF ACTIVITIES TO HAPPEN IN
THESE COMMUNITIES. THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO NORMALIZE WHAT
ADULTS DO. ADULTS ARE TWENTY ONE
AND OLDER IN THIS PARTICULAR AND
IF PARTICULAR VENUE- THERE IS NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR CHILDREN. TO
ACCESS THESE PRODUCTS MOST OF
THE PRODUCTS THAT WERE OFFERING
OR AT LEAST KIND OF.
EXEMPLIFYING THIS BILL IS CLOSED
CHILD RESISTANT TAMPER EVIDENT
SEAL PRODUCTS THAT CAN BE GIVEN
TO GAS- REALLY OTHER THAN THAT.
THE HOTEL'S REALLY WANT TO FIND
A WAY TO ENTER THE SPACE TO GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSUME IN A WAY THAT IS. NORMAL
WITH FAITH AND EDUCATE. WE FEEL
LIKE THIS BILL GIVES US THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE REVENUE.
TO INCREASE INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF RETAIL THAT GOES ON IN THIS
IN THE STATE. AND INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF TAX DOLLARS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AS WELL. THEY'LL HELP
THAT YOU SEE THAT THERE'S A
VALUE IN TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR
AND VOTE YES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I DON'T HAVE ANY OF
MY SHEET. ANY WITNESSES ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE ANYONE WANNA ADD ON
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. GOOD MORNING AMMAR
INTERNET ON BEHALF OF THE LONG
BEACH COLLECTIVE ASSOCIATION
SOCIAL EQUITY LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO TEMAS RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. THE COACHELLA
VALLEY CANNABIS ALLIANCE NETWORK
TORRANCE CANNABIS. COUNTY
ADVOCACY ALLIANCE. AND MRO
ANGELS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. DAVID CAN TANA WITH
THE CANNABIS BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE WANT TO
BRING BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I'M GONNA
MOTION. OUR MOTION GOT A SECOND
. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS QUESTIONS COMMENTS
COMMENTS QUESTIONS COMMENTS NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
KALRA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SPECTRUM HAS TRAVELED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU- TO THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON SOME AMENDMENTS TO
REFINE THE INTENT OF THE BILL I
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL WILL BE
GOING TO GEO COMMITTEE NEXT
WHERE I'M SURE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND THE BILL WILL CONTINUE-
AND IN THE MEANTIME I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AS AMENDED MR
SECRETARY LLOYD PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION BERMAN
AYE. BERMAN AYE FLORA. FLOOR AYE
BLOOM. M. I. BONTA IN CHENNAI
CUNNINGHAM DALY FONG. GIPSON
GIPSON I GRAYSON- ONE. OR NOT
VOTING LEE. I MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
SALAS. THANK WEBER. I JUST LOVE
THE SOUND OF MEMBERS VOTING AS
WELL. A BEAUTIFUL THING. ONCE
AGAIN THAT IS EIGHT WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND IT NEXT
AND I THINK THE LAST UP WE HAVE
A SMALL NUMBER CARILLO WITH A
NUMBER SEVEN. AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX. YOU GOT SAVED FROM
MR FLOOR PRESENTING FOR YOU. I
THINK IT'S BETTER THIS WAY. I
LIVE DANGEROUSLY WITHOUT A COVER
FOR MY- RIGHT. READY WHEN YOU
ARE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND I
APPRECIATE THE PATIENCE AND
BIPARTISANSHIP POTENTIAL
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL AS RAIN
HOUSING IN THE OTHER BUILDING
AND IT FEELS LIKE FOREVER TO GET
HERE. LET ME START OFF BY SAYING
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX WHICH
WILL EXPAND THE SCOPE OF WORK
FOR DENTAL ASSISTANTS THAT HAVE
COMPLETED A COURSE ON THE
RESPECTIVE PROCEDURES AND OF
COURSE ON INFECTION CONTROL TO
PERFORM CORONA POLISHING AND
APPLY. A PIT AND FISSURE
SEALANTS UNDER THE DIRECT
SUPERVISION OF A LICENSED
DENTIST CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
DENTAL ASSISTANTS TO PERFORM
MORE THAN TWENTY DIFFERENT
SUPPORT PROCEDURES UNDER THE
SUPER OF THE SUPERVISION OF A
LICENSED DENTIST INCLUDING TAKS
OF SIMILAR MAGNITUDE AND THOSE
IN THIS BILL. SUCH AS THE
REMOVAL OF THE POST EXTRACTION
TO- DRESSINGS AND DENTAL
STITCHES IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE A
SURVEY. REFLECTED THAT 87% OF
DENTAL OFFICES REPORTED HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME HIRING DENTAL
ASSISTANTS TO LAID OUT IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THERE WERE CLOSE TO ONE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS THAT POT
THAT PASSED THE RDA EXAM IN
CALIFORNIA BUT JUST LAST YEAR
ALONE THERE IS ONLY EIGHTY ONE
EDT HAS PROJECTED AN INCREASE
NEED OF MORE THAN NINE THOUSAND
DENTAL ASSISTANCE BY TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. ONE THOUSAND ARE
NEEDED IN L. A. COUNTY ALONE
WHICH IS THE AREA THAT I
REPRESENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST COUNTY THIS BILL IS A
NARROW CHANGE THAT WILL PROVIDE
MORE GROWTH OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE GOING INTO THE POSITION
AND MORE ACCESS TO PROVIDERS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WHILE PRESERVING
STANDARDS OF PATIENT CARE. I
HAVE TO WITNESS WITNESSES HERE
TO TALK MORE ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
JESSICA MORAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
AND DR ERRANT SHOT A PEDIATRIC
DENTIST THE PRACTICES AND SAN
FRANCISCO RIGHT. WEBER WOULD
LIKE TO GO FIRST. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS AROUND CAL DENTIST.
HERE TODAY AS THE SPONSORS AB
TWO TWO SEVEN SIX WHICH WOULD
EXPAND THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE FOR
DENTAL ASSISTANTS TO ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THE WORK FORCE SHORTAGES
THAT DENTAL PRACTICES ARE
EXPERIENCING. CD IS WORKING ON
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
THE WORK FORCE SHORTAGES SUCH AS
TREATING DENTAL ASSISTANT
PIPELINE PROGRAM STORE SMILE
COULD ISSUE THIS. AND THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS BUT WE KNOW
THAT WE MUST ALSO ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGES IN THE SHORT TERM AND
THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL AIMS TO
DO. I'M HERE TODAY WITH OUR MAIN
WITNESS DR AARON SHOT AND I'LL
BE HERE TODAY FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I THINK YOU MIGHT
NEED TO HIT THE BUTTON. THANK
YOU. WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS AMENDMENTS
WHICH MAKE THE BILL STRONGER. HI
MY NAME IS ERIN SHOT I'M A
PRACTICING PEDIATRIC DENTISTS IN
THE BAY AREA AND VICE CHAIR OF
CDS GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS COUNSEL.
DENTISTRY LIKE MANY OTHER
PROFESSIONS WAS HARD HIT BY THE
CODE PANDEMIC IN THE BEGINNING
OF THE SHELTER IN PLACE ORDERS
97% OF DENTAL OFFICES WERE
FORCED TO CLOSE COMPLETELY. NOW
TWO YEARS LATER MANY DENTAL
OFFICES ARE OPERATING AT
CAPACITY IN YOUR PRE PANDEMIC
LEVELS UNFORTUNATELY THE
PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED AN
ALREADY EXISTING DECLINING
DENTAL WORK FORCE PARTICULARLY
WITH THE DENTAL ASSISTANT
POSITION. ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN DENTAL ASSOCIATION OVER
THE PAST TEN YEARS THERE'S BEEN
NO NEARLY 50% DECLINE IN
ENROLLMENT AND DENTAL ASSISTANT
PROGRAMS NATIONALLY. IN
CALIFORNIA THE EIGHTY D. HAS
PROJECTED THAT THE THOUSANDS OF
VACANT DENTAL PUT DENTAL
ASSISTANT POSITIONS WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT DEMAND IT IS FAIR TO
SAY THERE'S AN ONGOING DENTAL
ASSISTANT SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA. DENTAL ASSISTANTS
PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN SUPPORTING
THE ENTIRE DENTAL TEAM CURRENTLY
DENTAL ASSISTANTS CAN ENROLL AND
COMPLETE COURSES APPROVED BY THE
DENTAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. AND
RECEIVE CERTIFICATIONS TO DO
THESE PROCEDURES BUT CANNOT
UTILIZE THE SKILLS UNTIL THEY
COMPLETE THEIR RESIDENT
REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANT
LICENSURE. AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
SIX WOULD EXPAND THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE OF DENTAL ASSISTANTS TO
INCLUDE CORONA POLISHING
EMPLACEMENT OF SEALANTS UNDER
THEIR DIRECT SUPERVISION OF A
DENTIST AND ONLY AFTER THEY HAVE
COMPLETED SUCCESSFULLY THE
APPROPRIATE CERTIFICATIONS AND
COURSE WORK. BOTH OF THESE
PROCEDURE ARE REVERSIBLE AND THE
SUPERVISING DENTIST WILL HAVE TO
BE LISTED ON THE PATIENT RECORD.
FOR SEALANTS THE SUPERVISING
DENTIST WILL NEED TO REVIEW THE
COMPLETED WORK BEFORE SENDING
THE PATIENT HOME. I PERSONALLY
WORK AT FOUR DIFFERENT PRACTICES
IN THE BAY AREA IN THE PAST YEAR
ALL FOUR HAVE EXPERIENCED
ASSISTANT SHORTAGES THAT
AFFECTED PATIENT CARE. WE'VE HAD
TO LIMIT THE NUMBER OF PATIENTS
THAT WE SCHEDULE OR CANCEL AND
RESCHEDULE COLLINS OF PATIENTS
OR ENTIRE PATIENT CARE DAYS.
WE'VE HAD TO HIRE ENTRY LEVEL
DENTAL ASSISTANCE JUST TO KEEP
THE DOORS OPEN. ECA'S GET THEIR
ERTIFICATES FOR XRAYS INFECTION
CONTROL AND CRONA POLISHING BUT
BECAUSE OF EXISTING LAW RONO
POLISHING CAN ONLY BE DONE BY
OUR R. D. A.'S. PLACING GREATER
WORK BURDEN ON OUR IDEAS THAT WE
DO HAVE. AS THEY CANNOT SHARE
THE DUTY WITH D. A.'S. SEVERAL
OTHER STATES ALREADY ALLOW FOR
DENTAL ASSISTANTS TO PERFORM
THESE DUTIES WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
CERTIFICATIONS. WERE AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY SIX TO PASS A DENTAL
ASSISTANT WOULD STILL NEED TO
COMPLETE THE REQUIRED
CERTIFICATIONS BEFORE PERFORMING
THESE DUTIES. WHICH ADDS AN
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF PATIENT
PROTECTION. THIS BILL WILL HELP
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE DENTAL
ASSISTING WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
ISSUES THAT DENTAL OFFICES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ARE
EXPERIENCING BY ALLOWING DENTALASSISTANTS TO PRACTICE TO THE
LIMITS OF THEIR CERTIFICATION.
AND BALANCE THE NEED OF DENTAL
PRACTICES WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO
HIGHER TEAM MEMBERS REYES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT- AND I THINK WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WE WANT
TO INVITE THEM UP- WE HAVE
MELODY RAND OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSISTING
ALLIANCE COALITION. JENNIFER
TANNAHILL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENISTS
ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MELODY
RANDOLPH. AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING OVER SEVENTY
THOUSAND DENTAL ASSISTANTS AND
DENTAL ASSISTING EDUCATORS. WE
HAVE MANY CONCERNS WITH THIS
CHANGED OUR SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
ALL ADDRESS JUST A FEW HERE.
NUMBER ONE THESE ARE NOT BASIC
SUPPORTIVE DUTIES AS DEFINED. OF
THE UNLICENSED DA. IN BE IN P.
SEVENTEEN FORTY CURRENT POLICY
REQUIRES THE USE OF A HANDPIECE.
THIS DRUG CAUSES FRICTION AND
HEAT AND CAN POTENTIALLY KILL
THE NERVE OF THE TOOTH AND
DAMAGE SOFT TISSUE. THE
PHOSPHORIC ACID USED DURING
SEALANT PLACEMENT DAMAGES THE
OUTER LAYER OF THE ENAMEL IN
ORDER FOR THE SEALANT TO STICK.
IF IT TOUCHES SOFT TISSUE IT'LL
BURN IT WITHIN SECONDS. DOES
THIS SOUND BASIC AND SUPPORTIVE.
LACK OF FUNCTIONAL. FOUNDATIONAL
EDUCATION AND TRAINING IS OUR
NUMBER TWO. THIS CHANGED HER
SCOPE OF PRACTICE WOULD ALLOW
SOMEONE TO PERFORM THESE DUTIES
WITHIN WEEKS OF THE FIRST DAY IN
DENTISTRY. THE TWO DAY COURSE
REFERENCED EARLIER ON THE
CERTIFICATION COURSES IT'S JUST
A TWO DAY COURSE. IN THESE
PROCEDURES WERE WRITTEN WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT PEOPLE TAKING
THEM WILL ALREADY HAVE. A YEAR'S
WORTH OF EDUCATION TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE WE CAN'T POSSIBLY
COVER THE FOUNDATIONAL KNOWLEDGE
AN ASSISTANT NEEDS PRIOR TO
PERFORMING THESE DUTIES. IN
THESE SHORT COURSES. AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY SIX INCREASES THE
INSTRUCTIONAL HOURS TO CUT HAIR
FROM A THOUSAND HOURS TO TWELVE
HUNDRED HOURS. BUT A DA CAN
PLACE PHOSPHORIC ACID ON A
TOOTH. AND AFTER SIXTEEN HOURS
OF EDUCATION. THAT SOUNDS CRAZY
. DENNIS SUPERB. CONTRARY TO
WHAT THE BILL'S SPONSOR WOULD
LEAD YOU TO BELIEVE THE DENTIST
RARELY SUPERVISORS DURING THESE
PROCEDURES. AND LASTLY THIS BILL
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE STAFFING
SHORTAGE IN FACT WE BELIEVE THAT
MOVING THESE DUTIES FROM THE RTA
TO THE DA WILL MAKE THE SHORTAGE
WORSE. AS WE HAVE HEARD FROM
NUMEROUS MEMBERS OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT TRAINED AND
SEASONED RDAS. WILL LEAVE
DENTISTRY VIEWING THIS AS A HUGE
STEP IN THE DESTRUCTION OF THEIR
CAREER. PLEASE CONSIDER THE LONG
TERM CONSEQUENCES TO THIS
DRASTIC CHANGE IN THE DENTAL
ASSISTING SCOPE OF PRACTICE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE ON AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
SIX. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JENNIFER TANAH
HELL WITH AARON REED AND
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENISTS
ASSOCIATION. CITY HA ECHOES THE
DENTAL ASSISTING ALLIANCES
CONCERNS FOR PATIENT SAFETY WITH
THIS BILLS LACK OF FOUNDATIONAL
EDUCATION BEFORE USING
PHOSPHORIC ACID ETCH AND
MOTORIZED HAND TOOLS INSIDE A
CHILD'S MOUTH. WITH POTENTIALLY
JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS ON THE
JOB LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING. THERE ARE TWO
TYPES OF DENTAL ASSISTANTS ONE
THE UNLICENSED DENTAL ASSISTANT
AND TO THE LICENSED REGISTERED
DENTAL ASSISTANT. OR RDA. THE
UNLICENSED DENTAL ASSISTANT IS
ON THE JOB TRAINED NO BACKGROUND
CHECK IN IS GENERALLY PAID
MINIMUM WAGE. A LICENSED RDA HAS
TWO PATHS TO ENTRY WHICH ARE
EITHER OF FIFTEEN MONTHS ON THE
JOB TRAINING CERTIFIED BY A
DENTIST. OR COMPLETION OF A
BOARD APPROVED EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM THE LICENSED RTA EARNS
MORE THAN MINIMUM WAGE UP TO
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR IN THE BAY AREA USUALLY
WITH BENEFITS WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE FROM THE
MINIMUM WAGE UNLICENSED DENTAL
ASSISTANT POSITION. THIS BILL
DOES NOT FIX A BARRIER TO ENTRY
PROBLEM BECAUSE THERE ALREADY
EXISTS AN ON THE JOB TRAINING
OPTION TO BECOME A LICENSED RDA
THE BARRIER TO ENTRY IS VERY LOW
. IT IS AN EXCELLENT ENTRY POINT
INTO THE ORAL HEALTH CARE FIELD
STAFFING SHORTAGES THAT EXIST
CAN BE ADDRESSED THROUGH
INCREASED PAY AND BENEFITS. WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE CAREER
LADDER FOR LICENSED RDAS WILL
COLLAPSE AS A DENT AS DENTAL
OFFICES WILL BE INCENTIVIZED TO
INSTEAD HIRE A PERSON WITH NO
EXPERIENCE AND INADEQUATE
TRAINING TO DO THESE PROCEDURES
FOR MINIMUM WAGE WITHOUT
BENEFITS. THEREBY MAKING THE
LICENSED RDA CATEGORY EVAPORATE
. BECAUSE CORONA POLISHING
SEALANTS ARE THE MAIN PROCEDURES
PERFORMED BY LICENSED RDAS. THIS
BILL INCENTIVIZES DENTAL OFFICES
TO FIRE THE LICENSE RDAS AND
REPLACE THEM WITH MINIMUM WAGE
AND LYFT AND SIMPLY. PORTABILITY
IS ANOTHER ISSUE MEANING A
LICENSED RDA CAN COMMAND A GOOD
WAGE IF SHE MOVED TO ANOTHER
CITY OR OUT OF STATE WITH HER
LICENSE IT'S MORE DIFFICULT FOR
AN UNLICENSED DENTAL ASSISTANT
SAID VANCE THROUGH THE CAREER
LADDER TO INCREASE PAY AND-
BENEFIT OPPORTUNITIES. NOTABLY
THERE IS NOT CONSENSUS AMONG
DENNIS ABOUT THIS BILL SOME
DENNIS SUPPOSED TO GIVING THESE
PROCEDURES TO UNLICENSED STAFF.
HOWEVER WITH THE LATE NOTICE
THAT A REMOTE TELECONFERENCE
OPTION WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE
TODAY DENNIS ALONG WITH DENTAL
HYGIENISTS AND DENTAL ASSISTANTS
WERE UNABLE TO TRAVEL TO
SACRAMENTO TO OPPOSE THE BILL IN
PERSON. IT IS FOR THESE REASONS
THAT CITY HA MUST RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- AND WE WANT TO OPEN
UP TO ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL WHO JUST WANNA ADD ON. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M
FRED NO- REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION OF DENTAL SUPPORT
ORGANIZATIONS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. THING NINE ONE
BRING BACK TO COLLEGE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. POLITICS
DR WEBER. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR PRESENTING
THIS BILL AND PLEASE FORGIVE ME
IF SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
ASK YOU- COVERED IN YOUR
PRESENTATION I HAD TO RUN OUT
FOR ANOTHER- OBLIGATION. I'M
WHAT IS THE- FOR ANYONE UP HERE
ACTUALLY WHAT IS THE OUR
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS FOR A
REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANT AND
A REGISTERED DENTAL HYGIENIST AS
FAR AS- THE HOURS THE TIME THE
COURSES. THERE ARE. ON THE JOB
TRAINING. SORRY THANK YOU I'M ON
THE JOB TRAINING FIFTEEN MONTHS-
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL COURSEWORK
INFECTION CONTROL X. RAY- AND
THEN CORONA POLISH TO BE
ELIGIBLE TO SIT FOR THE RTA
WRITTEN EXAM OR GOING THROUGH AN
RDA APPROVED PROGRAM AND THEY'RE
USUALLY ABOUT TEN MONTHS IN
LENGTH. AND FOR THIS PARTICULAR
BELL- FOR THE DENTAL ASSISTANT
IS THERE ANY TIME LIMIT THAT
THEY NEED TO BE PRACTICING
BEFORE THEY CAN- GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS. BEFORE DENTAL
ASSISTANTS THERE'S ALSO ON THE
JOB TRAINING AND THEY HAVE TO
COMPLETE THEIR INFECTION CONTROL
AND OF COURSE ON THAT CALIFORNIA
DENTAL PRACTICE ACT WITHIN THEIR
FIRST YEAR OF BEING ON THE JOB
AND ONLY AFTER THEY FINISH THE
ON THE JOB TRAINING AND THOSE
TWO CERTIFICATIONS WOULD THEY BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE COURSES FOR
CORONA POLISHING AND THE
SEALANT. SO THEY WOULD NOT- BE
ABLE TO START PRACTICING WITHIN
WEEKS OF BEING HIRED THEY WOULD
HAVE TO COMPLETE ALL THE
NECESSARY TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATIONS AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY GET CERTIFIED FOR
THESE TWO- DUTIES BEFORE THEY
CAN BEGIN PRACTICING AND HOW
MUCH IS THAT TIME. THE TRAINING
THAT THEY GO THROUGH. I'M I AM
NOT SURE THE HOURS OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD BUT IT IS IT HAS TO
BE DONE WITHIN THEIR FIRST YEAR
OF BEING. HIRED YOU CAN DO THE
TWO HOURS OF THAT- IS IT ALREADY
A AND THEN THE EIGHT HOURS OF
INFECTION CONTROL THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO OKAY. I'M SO
THAT'S A TOTAL OF TEN HOURS- AND
I'M SORRY. YOU WERE GOING TO
THANK I WAS JUST GONNA SAY I CAN
ADDRESS THAT YEAH THE INFECTION
CONTROL IS EIGHT HOURS. THE
DENTAL PRACTICE ACT IS TWO
HOURS. THE CROWN OF POLISH IS.
TWELVE OKAY SO AGAIN WITH IN A
WEEK OR TWO THEY COULD. BE DOING
THESE PROCEDURES OKAY. I'M WHAT.
WHAT ARE THERE ANY RISK
ASSOCIATED WITH THE- POLISHING
THERE ANY COMPLICATIONS. IN
THEORY THERE'S COMPLICATIONS
THERE COULD BE COMPLICATIONS-
BUT SOME OF THE OTHER- TASKS
THAT DA'S CAN DO THERE'S ALSO
THAT SAME RISK IF SOMEONE IS
CARELESS AND THIS IS WHY WE DO
ON THE JOB TRAINING WE MAKE SURE
THAT THE QUALITY AND THE SAFETY
IS THERE WHEN OUR ASSISTANTS ARE
PERFORMING THESE DUTIES OF THE
V. I'VE NEVER ACTUALLY SEEN.
SOMEONE HAVE DAMAGE FROM CORONA
POLISHING THAT'S- IT'S A IT'S A
MINIMALLY INVASIVE- YOU REMOVE A
VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF TO
STRUCTURE AND IT'S REALLY THE
BIO PHONE THAT YOU'RE REMOVING-
IT'S REALLY CONSIDERED
COMPLETELY REVERSIBLE. SO WHAT
WOULD BE SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
COMPLICATIONS. IF YOU HAD-
PRESSURE APPLIED TO THE TOOTH
FOR AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
TIME YOU COULD OVER HEAT THE
TOOTH BUT NO ONE'S NO ONE'S
POLISHING THAT WAY YOU KNOW
EVERYBODY'S ON A TIME SCHEDULE
NO ONE'S GOING TO HOLD. AN
INSTRUMENT ON A TOOTH FOR TWO
MINUTES TO COOK THE POP THAT IS
NOT WHAT HAPPENS ALSO THERE IS A
SPECIFIED TIME. THERE'S MORE IS
. SO IS THERE A SPECIFIED TIME.
THERE'S NOT A SPECIFIED TIME BUT
IN PERFORMING THAT DUTY YOU
REALLY YOU CLEAN THE SURFACE OF
THE TOOTH YOU'RE CONSTANTLY
MOVING IN YOUR MOVING IN GENTLE
CIRCLES AND YOU'RE MOVING.
RATHER QUICKLY IF ANYONE HAS
EVER HAD A DENTAL CLEANING YOU
KNOW. THEY'RE NOT SITTING THERE
IN ONE SPOT FOR TWO MINUTES OR
OR FOR A PROLONGED AMOUNT OF
TIME WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO DO
DAMAGE. OKAY AND SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THERE COULD BE
THERMAL DAMAGE WHICH WOULD LEAD
TO NERVE DAMAGE. IN THEORY I'VE
NEVER SEEN THAT HAPPEN OKAY. I'M
CAN YOU TELL HOW MUCH PRESSURE
SOMEONE IS APPLYING BY WATCHING
THEM. YOU CAN BECAUSE YOU AN
SEE THE COP FLEXING OR THE IF
YOU'RE USING A PERSONAL TO PRO
FOR YOU CAN SEE HOW MUCH THE
BRUSH BRISTLES ARE FLEXING. OKAY
AND WHAT IS THE COMPLICATIONS OF
STEALING. SEALANTS- BASICALLY
THE BIGGEST RESO THE PHOSPHORIC
ACID ETCH THAT THEY'RE REFERRING
TO IS NO GREATER DAMAGE THAN YOU
YOUR PATIENT WHO'S DRINKING COCA
COLA MOUNTAIN DEW AND SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES AND ACIDIC
BEVERAGES ON THE REGULAR THE-
THAT PROLONGED DAMAGE- THAT A
PATIENT MIGHT DO TO THEMSELVES
IS GREATER THAN WHAT YOU WOULD
HAVE FROM. I. TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY SECOND ASSETS- YES IT ADD
SHE WANTS THE CYLINDERS ON THE
CEILING AND THE BONDING AGENT
ARE FILLING IN THE STRUCTURE
THAT HAS BEEN ACID EDGE SO NOW
THAT THAT STRUCTURE IS
COMPLETELY PROTECTED. THE ASSET
AS JUST PREPARES THE TWO
STRUCTURES SO THAT IT CAN BONTA
THOSE AGENTS ON. THE ACTUAL
POLISH OR THE SEALANT THAT IS
PUTTING IS FLOWN INTO THE-
FLOWED INTO THE GROOVES OF THE
TOOTH AND CREATES IT CREATES A
SEAL SO THAT BACTERIA CANNOT GET
INTO THOSE DEEP GROOVES AND
BECAUSE THE CAT. THAT THE
SOCIALLY LIKE A TED TO MAKE IT
LIKE LAYMAN'S TERMS IT'S ALMOST
LIKE A MANICURE. EXCEPT APPLIED
TO THE TWO MEN TRAPPED IN THE
PROPER WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT
BACTERIA CONTAMINATION IS
ELIMINATED AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
AND THEN- SEALED TO SEAL OUT-
THE POSSIBILITY OF- ACTOR
GETTING INTO INTO THE TO THINK
HOUSING- CAPPY. OKAY SO. WITH
THE- POLISHING THEIR IS A RISK
OF- THERMAL DAMAGE EADING TO
NERVE DAMAGE WITH THE SEALANT
THERE IS. YOU'RE USING SOMETHING
ACIDIC SO THERE IS THAT RISK
THEIR- SORRY IF YOU. IF I CAN
JUST ADD ALL OF WHICH DOCTOR
JUST SAID IT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE
BUT AGAIN THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT
WE'RE TAKING SOMEBODY WHO'S
NEVER EVEN WORKED POTENTIALLY IN
A PATIENT'S MOUTH WITH MINIMAL
TRAINING BEING ABLE TO DO THESE
DUTIES WHICH HAS JUST BEEN SAID
WE ARE TAKING AWAY SERVICES OF
THE ENAMEL THAT YOU CAN'T GET
BACK TO THESE ARE. IRREVERSIBLE
DUTIES THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE
DONE BY SOMEBODY WHO DOESN'T
EVEN KNOW HOW TO RENTS AN
ASPIRATE MUCH LAST. USE THE HAND
PIECE IN THE MOUTH AND
PHOSPHORIC ACID. RIGHT OKAY WELL
MY QUESTION I WAS GOING TO BE SO
WE TALKED ABOUT- THE POTENTIAL
NERVE DAMAGE WE TALKED ABOUT THE
AESTHETIC. AND YOU HAD STATED
BEFORE THAT DENTAL ASSISTANTS
HAVE SIMILAR RISK WITH THE
THINGS THAT THEY ARE ALLOWED TO
DO LOOKING AT WHAT THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO DO WHAT IS. WHAT IS
IT THAT THEY DO NOW THAT HAS
SIMILAR RISKS TO WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING OR WHAT YOU ARE
PROPOSING. CHAIR PLACING AND
REMOVING RUBBER DAMS- THERE'S A
CLAMP THAT COULD IF IMPROPERLY
PLACED IMPINGE ON THE TISSUE. I
AM PLACING AND THAT WOULD CAUSE
NERVE DAMAGE NOT NERVE DAMAGE
BUT WOULD COME BECAUSE- DAMAGE
TO THE GUM TISSUE AND- APERI
DONNELLY COMPROMISE PATIENT THAT
TISSUE DAMAGE COULD BE LONGER
TERM- SAME THING WITH PLACING
WEDGING AND REMOVING MATRICES
FOR SORT OF PRODUCT- PROCEDURES
THAT- THOSE. METERS FANS CAN
OPERATE THE GUM TISSUE-
TEMPORARILY AND IT HEALS- INTER
AURAL IMPRESSIONS- THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE A PATIENT COULD
GAG. ON THE MATERIAL IF NOT DONE
PROPERLY AND EVEN IF DONE
PROPERLY AND THAT APPLIES TO ANY
OF THESE I EAT ANY OF THESE
PROCEDURES DONE PROPERLY STILL
RUN RISKS OF SMALL THINGS.
HAPPENING WITH THAT ARE USUALLY-
SOMETHING THAT THE PATIENT CAN
RECOVER FROM WITH MINIMAL
INCIDENT- AND THAT'S THE SAME
MATT THAT WOULD GO THE SAME WAY
AS- PROFI POLISHING. SO THE
PATIENT GAGS WHAT ARE YOU
CONCERNED ABOUT ASPIRATION.
ASPIRATION VOMITING-
ACCIDENTALLY SWALLOWING MATERIAL
THAT'S. I'M ADDITIONALLY
REMOVING ORTHODONTIC SEPARATOR
SOMETIMES ORTHODONTIC SEPARATORS
CAN BE MISPLACED AND GO TO START
TO FIRE SUBSTANTIVELY- REMOVING
SUTURES YOU COULD ACCIDENTALLY
INJURE A PATIENT REMOVING
SUTURES BY I ACCIDENTALLY
CUTTING THEM. I'M SO ALL OF
THESE THINGS ARE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO TRAIN OUR
ASSISTANCE IN AND WE AS THE
DENTISTS ARE RESPONSIBLE AND
LIABLE FOR ANY OF THOSE THINGS
THAT HAPPEN. I LIKE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PROPOSED BY
THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT
STRENGTHENS THOSE THOSE
PROTECTIONS ABOUT THE TYPE OF
TRAINING AND THE AMOUNT OF
TRAINING THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
GET THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
DOING THESE PROCEDURES WITHIN A
MONTH OF HIRING THEY'RE GOING TO
BE TRAINING ON THE JOB. MAN THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN
DEVELOP BUT THE- DIFFICULTY WE
HAVE IS THESE ASSISTANCE CAN
GOING GET THESE CERTIFICATES AND
LEARN THIS SKILL AND THESE ARE
SKILLS THAT ARE APPROVED BY THE
DENTAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA AND
PROVIDED BY THE DENTAL ASSISTANT
PROGRAMS- THEY TAKE THESE THESE
CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS AND THEN
THEY CAN'T USE THEM ON THE JOB.
AND SO WE ACTUALLY SEE IN IN-
ENVELOPING THIS N. THAT DA SCOPE
WILL GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO USE
THOSE SKILLS AND ADVANCE SO THAT
THEY HAVE MORE OF A SKILL
DEVELOPMENT LADDER INTO GO INTO
BECOMING AN RGA. WE WANT MORE RT
AS WE DON'T WANT HIM TO HAVE-
LET'S TRAIN DA'S WE WANT OUR
DÍAS TO BE AS FULLY TRAINED AND
FUNCTIONAL AND LICENSE AS
POSSIBLE BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS CREATES A PATHWAY. FOR
DEVELOPING THOSE SKILLS IN A
STEPWISE MANNER SO THAT THEY
CAN- EVENTUALLY MOVE FORWARD
INTO RDA POSITIONS AND GREATER
RESPONSIBILITY. YOUR DENTAL IS
THE HAVE- THE REQUIREMENT TO DO
CONTINUING EDUCATION COURSES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR SKILLS ARE-
CAN YOU KNOW UP TO PAR BECAUSE
YOUR RESIDENT AS I'M SURE YOU DO
AS A PHYSICIAN I DO- I'M- SURE
AS AS THE- RDAS. THEY THEY HAVE
TO. DO DENTAL ASSISTANTS HAVE TO
DO CONTINUING EDUCATION COURSES
TO MAKE SURE THAT. YOU KNOW
THEY'RE UP ON THE LATEST AND
GREATEST. MAYBE SOMETHING WALKIE
WITH ANATOMY THAT THERE THAT
THEY MAY NOT HAVE PICKED UP ON
IN THERE- ON THE JOB TRAINING.
THEN ASSISTANCE DO NOT HAVE ANY
REQUIRED COURSEWORK. THEY DON'T
HAVE TO AFTER THEY'VE TAKEN THE
INFECTION CONTROL IN THE DPA
THEIR FIRST YEAR THEY NEVER HAVE
TO DO IT AGAIN. IF THEY STAY IN
THE D. A. CATEGORY- THEY DON'T
HAVE ANY CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS AND IN FACT THE
DENTAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA HAS
NO JURISDICTION OVER. THE
UNLICENSED DENTAL ASSISTANT AND
THAT IS ONE OF OUR OTHER
CONCERNS HERE IS THAT THEY'D BE
ABLE TO DO THESE PROCEDURES AND
NOT HAVE TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION BECAUSE ARE NOT
LICENSED- YOU KNOW I AM.
CONCERNED WITH- EXPANDING THE
SCOPE WITHOUT AYE EXPANDING.
TRAINING AND TO HAVE COMPARABLE
TRAINING- AND THAT'S WHY I BEGAN
WITH ASKING WHAT IS YOU KNOW THE
TIME REQUIREMENT TO BECOME- A
REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANT ARE
REGISTERED DENTAL HYGIENIST I
UNDERSTAND WANTING TO TEACH AND
HOW PEOPLE GROW IN THE FIELD AND
I BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A
PROCESS FOR THAT- I WASN'T
REALLY SURE WHAT THE OVERALL-
REASONING FOR THE BILL WISE
BECAUSE I WOULD AS I WAS READING
IT WAS STATING SOMETHING ABOUT
THERE BEING A SHORTAGE. OF
DENTAL ASSISTANTS. BUT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW EXPANDING THEIR
SCOPE WOULD INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF DENTAL ASSISTANT- MAYBE YOU
TALKED ABOUT THAT AND IN THE
OPENING STATEMENT AND I JUST
MISSED IT BUT I JUST I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW. EXPANDING THE
SCOPE IS GOING TO BRING MORE
PEOPLE IN. I'M IF THERE IS AN
ISSUE WITH. NEEDING MORE PEOPLE
IN THE OFFICE TO DO THESE
PROCEDURES SO THAT THE DENTIST
CAN. YOU KNOW QUICKLY SEE
PATIENTS AND GET THEM IN AND
OUT. YOU DO HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
THAT YOU HAVE YOUR REGISTERED
DENTAL HYGIENIST IN YOUR
REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANT SO.
I I'M NOT SURE IF EXPANDING
SCOPE OF PRACTICE TO SOMETHING
ESPECIALLY FOR PROCEDURE THAT
DOES HAVE RISK. I'M IS. THE BEST
IDEA BUT I AM DEFINITELY- YOU
KNOW WILLING TO CONTINUE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR BELL AND
HOPEFULLY SHE WILL BE AND
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH- SOME
OF THE MEMBERS OF OPPOSITION TO.
COME TO A HAPPY MEDIUM THANK YOU
. THANK YOU DR WEBER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AND COLLEAGUES. YES MR LEE. I
DON'T HAVE A ESTARÁ PROBING AS
DR WEBER DOES ABOUT QUESTIONS
BUT I JUST GONNA SAY THAT- I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
OPPOSITION IS RAISING I'M
PERSONALLY SOMEONE WHO HAS A LOT
OF PERSONAL TRAUMA FROM DOING ON
DENTISTRY I HAVE GENETICALLY
TERRIBLE TEETH AND TERRIBLE LIKE
JHANSI BROTHER DENTISTRY
PROFESSIONALS AND WEARING MASKS
YOU CAN LOOKAT MY TEETH RIGHT
NOW. BUT SO I HAVE AND ALL SORTS
OF DIFFERENTIALS POKE AND PROD
ME AND I UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT IS TO HAVE THAT
PATIENT SAFETY AS SOMEONE WHO
HAS COME THROUGH A LOT OF THE
STUFF AND STILL GOES THROUGH-
BUT I DO HAVE A LOT OF FAITH IN
THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION FIGURES OUT
I THINK THE AMENDMENTS THAT.
WHAT THE- SUPERVISING DENTIST
REALLY ON THE HOOK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I HOPE SHE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION
TO MAKE SURE THAT. PATIENT
SAFETY. AND COMFORT OF COURSE.
IS THE HEART OF THIS AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY FOR YOU.
THANK YOU SO OVERLY ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES. AS A MEMBER CREE-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT
JUST TO ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS IS REALLY QUICKLY AS
WE LAID OUT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- 87% OF DENTAL OFFICES
REPORTED HAVING THE DIFFICULTY
HIRING DENTAL ASSISTANTS. IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THERE WERE CLOSE
TO ONE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS THAT
PASSED THE REGISTERED DENTAL
ASSISTANT EXAM IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT LAST YEAR ALONE THAT NUMBER
WAS ONLY EIGHTY ONE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE AN
INCREDIBLE JOB IN PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE AND INCREASING
HEALTH CARE ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE
REGARDLESS OF INCOME OR
LOCATION. DENTAL CARE IS PART OF
THAT SOLUTION AND YOU KNOW GOING
TO THE DENTIST ALREADY AS STATED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE IS
TRAUMATIC ENOUGH- ESPECIALLY I
WOULD SAY PEDIATRIC DENTISTRY IS
ONE OF THE HARDEST OF FIELDS OUT
THERE- DOING THIS TYPE OF WORK
FOR CHILDREN AND REALLY FOR ALL
ALL ADULTS THAT- WE FEEL
INCREDIBLY UNCOMFORTABLE ALREADY
AND FOR. THOSE OF YOU THAT THAT
KNOW ME AND KNOW ME WELL KNOW
THAT I WOULD NEVER PUT A BILL
FOR THAT ACTUALLY JEOPARDIZES
THE WORKFORCE OR JOBS FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE ALREADY DOING THIS TYPE
OF WORK THAT'S NOT WHERE I COME
FROM IT'S NOT MY PHILOSOPHY NOR
MY VALUES. WHAT ARE MY VALUES
THOUGH ARE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND I'M SAD TO REPORT
THAT DESPITE MULTIPLE ATTEMPTS
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION. AS
WELL AS THE SPONSORS TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION THEY
INITIALLY SAID YES WE WILL WORK
WITH YOU AND THEN COMPLETELY
DECLINED SO I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S ACTUALLY A GOOD WAY TO DO
WORK OR POLICY. AND SO- THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS MAKE THAT
CHAIN OF ACCOUNTABILITY
INCREDIBLY CLEAR ONE OF THE
INITIAL CONCERNS WAS LIABILITY
THE AMENDMENT THAT WE TOOK TO
MAKE THAT THE DENTISTS
RESPONSIBLE AND THE LIABILITY IS
A HUGE. STEP FORWARD AND COULD
AND ACTUALLY FINDING THAT
SOLUTION WE DID THAT ANDYET
HERE WE FIND OURSELVES YET
THEY'RE STILL HUMAN GLOOM ABOUT
THE WORK FORCE AND WHERE IT'S
GOING TO BE THE FACT IS THAT WE
NEED MORE MORE PEOPLE IN THIS
PARTICULAR. A PARTICULAR SPACE.
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO CALL THAT
TO. SO OF I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
FOR THIS WORK MY OFFICE THE
COMMITTEE. MANY STAFF FOR. A
REALLY GETTING INTO THIS THIS
ISSUE AND TRYING TO FIND
SOLUTIONS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO AT THE END OF THE DAY BE ABLE
TO ACCESS. GOING TO THE DENTIST
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU A SUMMER
THAT SOMEONE NUMBER CARILLO AND
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
STAKEHOLDERS FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL- I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. WOULD AYE AND
IT YOU KNOW COMMENT WAS MADE
ABOUT THE LATE NOTICE OF NO
PHONE TESTIMONY THERE WASTHEY
NOTICED OF THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL- AND SO I. WONDER IS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE PHONE TESTIMONY
TODAY DUE TO I. T. LIMITATIONS.
BUT WE HAVE RECEIVED PLENTY OF
COMMENTS THROUGH OUR ADVOCATE
PORTAL. AND WE ENCOURAGE ANYONE
WHO FEELS THEY HAVE NOT HAD A
CHANCE TO COMMENT TO DO SO TO
STILL SUBMIT COMMENTS. THROUGH
THE ADVOCATE PORTAL- WHILE WHILE
I DO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
STILL DISAGREEMENT. AS TO
WHETHER THE PROCEDURES UNDER
THIS BILL ARE REVERSIBLE. THERE
WILL ALSO HAVE TO BE ONE OR MORE
SUPERVISING DENTISTS WHO ARE
PUTTING THEIR LICENSE ON THE
LINE. THE RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED- THERE
SHOULD BE AN EVEN CLEARER CHAIN
OF RESPONSIBILITY AND THEREFORE
MORE PRESSURE ON THE SUPERVISING
DENTIST OVERSEE THE DENTAL
ASSISTANTS. THAT SAID I KNOW
THERE ARE STILL OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS. OF REGARDING THE RDA
WORKFORCE I WANT TO RECOMMEND
THAT THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR.
CONTINUING CONTINUE DISCUSSING
THESE ISSUES WITH THE OPPOSITION
AS THE BILL MOVES FOR FROM WHAT
I SAW. THERE IS A DESIRE FROM
EVERYBODY TO TIM. DID YOU KNOW
HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND YOU KNOW
TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES SO. I
ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY WHO'S
PRESENTED TODAY TO CONTINUE
WORKING TOGETHER- TO TRY TO
ADDRESS ANY ANY OUTSTANDING
ISSUES THAT EXIST. LASTLY I
UNDERSTAND THE DENTAL BOARD HAS
NOT HAD A CHANCE TO FORMALLY
REVIEW THE BILL. SO WE WILL KEEP
AN EYE ON THE CONVERSATIONS AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD. WITH
THOSE CONSIDERATIONS I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL WITH THE
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS. AT THIS
TIME- AND WE. NEED A MOTION. AND
A SECOND. THE LEFT GOT A MOTION.
AND SECOND GOT A SECOND. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I FLOOR FLOOR I BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE CHAN. AND
NOT VOTING CUNNINGHAM. MA'AM I
DALY. FONG FONG I GIPSON GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON IRWIN BERMAN I ME
MAY I MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA I
AM MULLIN MULLIN AYE SALAS.
THANK WEBER. THAT BILLS OUT WITH
ELEVEN VOTES FULLY THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT WRAPS UP THE
PRESENTATIONS FOR TODAY WE SAW A
LOT OF VOTING FOR TODAY- SO WHY
DON'T WE START AND WE WILL NEED
LOTS OF MOTIONS AND SECOND ON
ALL THE BILLS- THAT THAT WERE
PRESENTED WHILE WE'RE
SUBCOMMITTEE LET'S START WITH
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER ALWAYS OVER
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- GOT A
MOTION IN THE SECOND. MR
SECRETARY IF YOU CAN CALL THE
VOTE FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
BERMAN HI. BERMAN I FLOOR FLOOR
I BLOOM. BLOOM AYE BONTA AYE
BONTA AYE CHAN. AND I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. DALLI
DALLI AYE FONG. FONG I GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON- IRWIN BERMAN
EILEEN. MAY I MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
SALAS. THANK WEBER. INSING
CALENDARS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- NEXT
LET'S MOVE ON THE AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO WIN
THE CHAIR HAS AN AYE RECCO ON
THIS BILL. GOT A MOTION IN THE
SECOND. MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE VOTE MOTIONS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I FLOOR FLOOR I BLAM BLAM AYE
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE CHAN AND I
CUNNINGHAM. I KNOW HIM I DALLI.
DALLI I'D FONG. ON AYE GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON IRWIN IRWIN
KILEY MAY I MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN MULLIN AYE
SALAS. IN WEBER IRAQ THE SOME A.
B. SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE IS OUT
WILL BE THE ROLE OF AN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THIS PROVIDES AN
ITEM NUMBER TWO THE B. SEVENTEEN
FORTY BY SOME MEMBER MARTUCCI
THE CHAIR HAS AN I
RECOMMENDATION. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL VOTE. MOTION IS TO
PASS THE COMING OUT OF
PREPARATIONS BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE FLOOR. FLOOR I BLAM. BLAM
AYE BONTA AYE BONTA AYE CHAN.
AND I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
DALI. DALI AYE FONG. FONG I
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON R.
ONE. R. ONE EILEEN. A. I.
MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
ON AYE SALAS THANK WEBER. IRAQ
THAT BILL IS OUT- WILL BE THE
ROLE OF AN OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS NEXT OF HIS ASSEMBLY- IS
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN BYE BYE SIR
FLOOR THE CHAIR HAS A- I AS
AMENDED RECOMMENDATION MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMAND OF PREPARATIONS
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE FLORA
FLOOR I BLOOM BLOOM AYE BONTA
AYE BONTA AYE CHAN CHAN I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. DALLY
DALLY I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSONR. ONE R. ONE
EILEEN HI MAY I MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN ON AYE SALAS.
THING WEBER. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL IS AND EITHER OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS- NEXT UP WE HAVE
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SIX. THE
TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX BY
MAIENSCHEIN I THINK RIGHT YEAH
WE'VE BEEN TO THAT ONE YET. I
MAIENSCHEIN. GOT A MOTION. GOT A
SECOND THE CHAIR RECOMMENDATIONS
I AS AMENDED MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL OF A MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I FLOOR. FLOOR AYE BLOOM. BLOOM
AYE BONTA AYE BONTA AYE CHAN.
AND I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
DALI. DALI AYE FONG. FONG AYE
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
IRWIN R. ONE EILEEN. MAY I AM A
- MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE SALAS THANK. WEBER
IRAQ THAT BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT
UP IS AGENDA ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
AB TWENTY FOUR OH SEVEN BY
O'DONNELL- WITH A HIGH
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
GOT A MOTION GOT A SECOND AND-
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE.
MOTIONS TO PASS THE COMMAND
PUBLIC SAFETY BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE FLOOR FLOOR I BLOOM. BLOOM
AYE BONTA AYE BONTA AYE CHAN
CHAN I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
DALI DALI AYE FONG. FONG AYE
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON IRWIN-
WHEN I ONLY. A. I. MCCARTY
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN. MULLIN
AYE SALAS SALAS I ATTAIN WEBER.
ALL RIGHTS THAT BILL IS OUT
LEAVE THE ROLL OVER FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS NEXT UP WE HAVE AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER AND AB TWENTY SIX
ELEVEN THE OLD- AB TWENTY SIX
ELEVEN BY SOME MEMBER DALY THE
CHAIR HAS AYE OF. LOOKING FOR A
MOTION AND SECOND GOT MOTION GOT
A SECOND- MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL VOTE. THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS BERMAN. HI BERMAN I FLOOR
FLOOR I AM BLOOM. M. I. BONTA
AYE BONTA AYE CHAN CHAN I
CUNNINGHAM. I AM I DIALING DALY
AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON. IRWIN BERMAN EILEEN
ME AYE MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN. MULLIN AYE SALAS SALAS I
TEN. WEBER THAT BILL IS OUT WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS NEXT UP IS AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SIX BISOLA MEMBER
CALDERON THE JERICHO IS I. AS
AMENDED LOOKING FOR A MOTION AND
A SECOND. GOT A MOTION. OKAY GOT
A SECOND. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL VOTE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH BERMAN HI BERMAN I FLOOR
. OR NO. BLOOM WHEN I BONTA AYE
BONTA AYE CHAN. CUNNINGHAM DALY
. ALLEN NOW FONG. FONG NO GIPSON
. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SIX. A BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA IN REGARDS TO
LICENSEE DISCIPLINE FOR ABORTION
PROVIDERS. OUR CALDERON. GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON. R. ONE- WHEN EILEEN
HI MAY I MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA
HI MULLIN MULLIN AYE SALAS.
SALAS SALAS I THINK WEBER MY
RIDE. THAT BILLS OUT WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
NEXT UP IS THIS AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT BYE BYE SUMMER
SMITH GOT A MOTION GOT A SECOND
CHAIR AS I RECOMMENDATION MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY BERMAN HI BERMAN I
FLOOR FLOOR I BLAME. THEM AYE
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE CHAN CHAN I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE DOLLY
DALI AYE FONG. FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. IRWIN BERMAN
EILEEN A. I. MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA I AM ON. MULLIN AYE SALAS
. SALAS I THINK. THIS IS A CHEN
I'M TWELVE AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT BY SOMEONE NUMBER
SMITH IN REGARDS. CAN I WEBER
ANOTHER THING THAT BILL IS OUT
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS OF WHICH I THINK
IS JUST MCCARTY IS HE THE NO
GRAYSON IS NOT HERE YET. YEAH
GRAYSON MCCARTY COME ON DOWN-
THAT BILLS OUT NEXT UP WE VOTED
ON THE COVER BILL ALREADY RIGHT
SO LET'S SKIP TO THE COOPER
BILL'S AGENDA ITEM FOURTEEN.
WHAT'S THAT. YET YEAH WHAT IS
GOING TO RUN THROUGH THE FOR THE
FOR THE FOR THE ONES WE HAVE A
VOTE ON YEAH THEN WE'LL COME
BACK THROUGH THE OTHER ONES- AB.
THIS IS AGENDA ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FOUR BY
COOPER- CHAIR AS IRAQ- WHENEVER
MOTION IS SECOND. OUR MOTION. WE
GET A SECOND. NO IDEA I I'VE
GIVEN YOU GOOD YEAH I GOT IT ALL
RIGHT MOTION BY DOING A SECOND
BITE BY GIBSON I DON'T KNOW WHY
THIS ONE. EVERYONE GOT NERVOUS
ABOUT- THE COOPER CONTRACTORS
WORKERS COMPENSATION INSURANCE
ROGER IS IRAQ OF MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL VOTEMOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
INSURANCE BERMAN HI BERMAN I
FLOOR FLOOR I BLOOM THEM AYE
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE CHAN CHAN I
CUNNINGHAM. I AM NOW DOUBLING
DOWN A NOTE FONG. GIPSON GIPSON
I GRAYSON IRWIN BERMAN EILEEN.
MAY I. MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN MULLIN AYE SALAS- CITING
AN AYE WEBER. AWRY THAT BILL IS
OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT UP IS AGENDA
ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY FIVE BY COOPER AYE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
LOOKING FOR A MOTION AND A
SECOND GOT THE MOTION IN THE
SECOND THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE COMMAND OF
PREPARATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN I
FLOOR. FLOOR AYE BLOOM. M. I.
BONTA HI BONTA AYE CHAN. CHAN I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. DALI.
FONG GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
IRWIN BERMAN EILEEN MAY I
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA I'M ON
MINE I SALAS- CITING IN AYE
WEBER HOWEVER I THAT BILL IS OUT
WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND NOW LET'S ROLL BACK
THROUGH THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
WHO WAS HERE THE WHOLE TIME IS
ALREADY VOTED ALL THE BILLS AND
SO I THINK LET'S DO KALRA.
AGENDA ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY FOUR- MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE. RUN BACK
THROUGH THE- VOTE. YEAH. AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. BONTA AYE BONTA
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NO
DIALING DIALING NOW FONG. ON NOT
VOTING GRAYSON MCCARTY THANK CAN
I WEBER HOWEVER I. KALRA IS BILL. I SALAS NOW. AND THEN. TO THE
CREE ONE X. YEP PERFECT SO LET'S
GO GO BACK TO THE CARILLO ONE
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO IT WHICH HAS AN
I. AS AMENDED RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CHAIR JUST SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL VOTE. REBECCA THE
VOTE. AT YEAH. GRAYSON MULLIN
MULLIN I TEN NINE AND MCCARTY.
AND IT. SOUNDS LIKE. SOME.
YAMANA YEAH OKAY AND THEN WILL
YOU ALWAYS TAKE FROM THE TOP-
FOR A COUPLE COLLEAGUES WHO
ARRIVE MIDWAY THROUGH OUR-
LISTENING OF LET ME VOTING THANK
YOU EVERYBODY. GOOD TO SEE
EVERYONE. YEAH DAVID THAT DEVON
COMPLICATED THINGS.
YEAH. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SALAS SALAS I ATTAIN. CONSENT
CONSENT. THING I. YEAH YEAH AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE WHEN SALAS
SALAS I ATTAIN NINE. AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY MARTUCCI SALAS
OUTSIDE TANK WHEN I. AB TWENTY
ONE OH SEVEN FLORA I'M MEDINA.
UP YES I. SALAS SAUCE I. TEN
NINE. AB TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX
MAIENSCHEIN SALAS ALSO WRITING.
WHEN I. AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
SIX. CORREO SALAS- I HAVE
THOUSAND. AB TWENTY FOUR OH
SEVEN. O'DONNELL THANK AND I.
YOU CAME AROUND HERE SO I THINK
I HAVE. AB TWENTY SIX ELEVEN
DALY TANG AND I. AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SIX CALDERON TANG. I.
THAT WOULD BE THE TO COOPER
DAHLE.
YEAH.
FORTY SIX ZERO A SEVERE RARE
PUBLIC COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT AND
IT WILL KIND OF WATCHING. SO THE
NUMBER THERE WE CAN'T EXACTLY
CORRECT. IF THEY DON'T HAVE THEM
OVER ANY. REPUBLICAN WHAT. REYES
AND THIS HAD A PROFOUND. I MEAN
I DON'T I DON'T THINK. THE NEW
HAD WE HAVE A- WATERPARK. WE
WANT.
ONE
FOR.
OKAY THANK YOU AND WITH THAT
MEETINGS ADJOURN.